pawn is another Queen there was rook b8
check could have been included there
before she - well what does that know
what does means that retakes of seven is
it is a big brother then ya gonna say
that's curse you got smiles a little bit
it's like a well forgot about that one
when I got that second point on she won
oh we haven't forgotten we have a we
have a great match here
[Music]
and round 2 has begun I'm not sure
there's a better way to start the
quarterfinals of the 2018 speech as
championship then with the young young
Christophe Duda who shocked the world
although apparently not my co-host when
he upset Sergey Karjakin in well it was
last one of the last rounds of the first
round upsetting many people's pick to
make it to the finals on the opposite
side of the bracket of the Cara Nakamura
but you say you saw it coming and so
let's ask you what exactly do you see
coming today between Sasha Grichuk and
young christophe Duda mr. Hess well I
did pick Duda to win that match of last
time I mean it's cardiac and I know that
was the upsets but special but Jude has
proven himself already it was really
impressive to see him in the bullet
portion of the last match against
cardiac in of course in the longer time
controls for shook cardiac and slightly
higher rated than Duda but still do does
2740 one of the best players in the
world he's only improving so I'll be
very fascinating to see that bullet
portion I feel like I said this every
single match week commentate but between
Grisha can do too and the bullet Danny
who do you think has the better odds
there you know honestly I at this point
I don't know what to expect
I'm definitely of the belief I think
like most people that the former world
blitz champion that big Alexander
grishnack nicknamed Sasha as you hear
that today everyone we get a lot of
questions why were you calling him Sasha
but Alexander Grichuk is a former world
blitz champion he's somebody who has a
very decent record at blitz and
wrappered even against guys like magnus
carlsen i think that Grichuk has been
very motivated in this event every year
that he's played and so far he's only
he's only lost to one man in the speed
chess championship Robert and you know
who that man is
and that man is not in the field this
year magnus carlsen isn't playing as he
prepares for the world championship so I
look at Grisham as a Dark Horse pick to
potentially win it all we have not seen
him take on Hikaru Nakamura in this
format and I'm not sure we're gonna see
him him this year either but as I look
at the brat
and see that he now no longer has to
face his fellow countrymen that being
circa cockin I feel like um you know
whether they would say it or not I feel
like he he's in a better position to
reach the finals and maybe he's been
before now of course young Christoph is
many people's view as maybe a potential
future world champion right so we're not
under estimating the talent of Duda and
clearly he's already made made those
seeing him as an underdog eat their
words once so um so we'll see what
happens but I'm gonna lean griffix way
and on that note of course looking at
the stats are stats also lean griffix
way but it's really not that big of a
favorite given dudas performance in the
match but as we find out in just a few
minutes who's gonna win regardless of
what the stats are Robin and I try to
say I want to remind everybody who's
here early that don't forget on Thursday
that's just two days from now we have
Geary vs. Aronian maybe maybe one of the
most anticipated matchups here in the
quarterfinals unfortunately my partner
in crime
Robert Hess will be on a plane at that
time heading to Batumi for the Olympia I
will be joined by grandmaster Eric
Hanson of the chess press so not
unfortunate for that Eric and I should
have a good time there but okay the the
next round rolls on and of course we
just talked about the fact that we have
Duda and grishnack and then on Thursday
we have Geary and Aronian but let's
remind everybody what they're playing
for here we have bigger prizes in in the
next round and of course there are
prizes potentially increasing based on
the fan participation Robert we're also
gonna do a raffle today do you have one
of these chest comm mugs I do not know
why didn't I ever get you one of those
that seems just mean of me too
because you know I don't drink coffee so
you're probably like oh I don't want to
tense that's the only reason I didn't I
didn't forget or anything so you're
right um but I will remind everybody
that's here now you can you can type
just you know enter the raffle the
raffle command exclamation point raffle
and you will be entered to win a free
giveaway here for our merch store make
sure you check out the merch store and
all all items purchased during the
species championship events
send that cash you get a free mug or
whatever it is you purchase and that
cash goes directly to the players to
help increase the price fun there so
thank you everyone for being here and
for playing along in the raffle Robert I
think we have all four of them we got
all four people here meaning me and you
we're accounted for but we also have mr.
mr. grishnack and young Christoph
anxiously waiting for a chess board to
explode on what do you got here
what do you got for me well I love Chris
jokes haircut he's looking very fresh
Sascha you know just looking like he's
ready for this match and I saw someone
in the chat earlier on twitch saying
that Grisha prepares hard for for it I
think it was Gary Mayer actually who
said it it's true we've seen time and
time again we should come into this
match none well this particular match
but he has come to his other matches
very well prepared Andy gave Carlsen all
they could handle in previous match as
well yep and you made the point that's
the only player who's beaten Sasha I'll
make the point back that precisely zero
players have beaten Duda in this format
so you're not to one-up you in the stats
column here but Duda has not been beaten
he's shown that he can handle
particularly bullet portion and Sasha
last time against niebo he beat me post
six to three yeah in that's three minute
portion I think that's gonna be very
interesting as well because I think in
the five minute portion I'm giving it to
Sasha I just think that he's a slightly
stronger player and with more time in a
clock yes he's a glutton for time
trouble but I think with that extra two
minutes he'll be okay but as the time
starts ticking down that's when I really
like Judah he is so quick with the mouse
and in the first round well we're gonna
we're gonna obviously stay tuned to what
those tiny little emote heads do during
the match here as they dance their way
up are fun little graphs that we really
really like making of course there's
both the odds to win match graph which
starts out a little bit differently
based on Grisha being the slight
favorite according to most people's view
and then there's the actual score
progression so we'll have some fun
keeping our eyes on that and I agree
with you Robert obviously at this point
you and I can talk about this until our
until our faces are blue or until we go
red in the face or something like that
but while we have 500 of you here early
oh my gosh we already have our first
chest Bey going crazy with the gifted
subs we love you chest may shout out to
the chat
arrived with her with her
acknowledgement of us pay she loves you
and everybody that's here Thank You Ches
Bay for for showing your support of the
channel and anyone who was interested in
and using their their emotes today
spamming the head of your favorite
player go for it but the arena kings is
rolling on Robert we had our first event
on Monday a lot more prizes we know you
made it to the finals last year I want
to remind everybody to make sure you
mark your calendars for every Monday
Wednesday and Friday as the arena kings
and all of your favorite streamers are
live in the chess category here on
Twitch and a season two has begun the
next event is tomorrow Wednesday at 5:00
p.m. Pacific but okay not much more we
can talk about because the players are
ready we're ready the prize fund total
tracker bars everything's ready here
chess Bay is ready it looks like Celebi
feels ready Moo BOTS ready
Robert anybody that we did you call your
mom oh my gosh your mom has texted me
right now she's also ready
your mom just let me know she's ready
for the match as well so I think we're
all ready to go I can't wait you know
I'm really and here we see the first
moves underway and that's the moment
we've all been waiting for
and look at Duda with the black pieces
quickly opting for Sicilian saying by g4
so I love this I love it early set up on
both sides because they're showing that
they're prepared to really battle
they're not afraid of the other and
they're also playing quite quickly which
demonstrates that well they've been here
before but also I think that they have
had specific preparation for this match
well you make a good point in the sense
that they're not not to say that
openings that are less well known mean
that they're not taking it as seriously
but you know we have usually two
different types of approaches in these
matches those who are really trying to
get things that are flexible and offbeat
and not reveal some of their classical
over the world preparation and those who
come ready and willing to challenge
their opponent in the most topical
theoretical lines and it feels like with
these two guys today
we're gonna get some sharp stuff and
both these guys trying to prove that
they out prepared their opponent we also
know that they both dumb preparation for
these matches based on what they've told
us in their interviews right yeah
absolutely and you know
the last hopeful at age 3 was an
important move because at that moment
black was threatening plane Knight takes
d4 followed by Pawnee 5 to open up that
Bishop on that g4 pawn so h3 curiously
has put Duda into a think here but I
mean I don't know h3 seems like the most
reasonable move as a reaction to the
fact that Knight 64:45 was a threat so
if I got black here I say well what's
White's idea why he's still flexible if
I can cast on either side I know that
people will look at this as a white has
to Castle queenside because you played
g4 but that's not really true your King
is actually quite safe on the Kings side
as well and it's really not unfathomable
to play pawn at 4 and cast them there's
f4 and the Castle kingside and just
immediately get a look on this F files
are pushing your pawns further I will
say the black lacks space in these type
of lines the you know look at the pieces
just at play here nothing for black has
passed its own third rank whereas for
white there's you know 374 pieces three
pawns a night on the fourth reckon okay
Chris you're keeping the options open he
will likely I still think you my castle
King side here because if your Castle
queenside you might walk into some sort
of black counter play where is it King
site I don't quite see how black gets
anything in response well one of the one
of the this is a you know typical sort
of Scheveningen Sicilian structure and
it does often look like black is just
much more passive than his opponent but
the point is at some point with things
you've already highlighted right a
timely trade and strike I did with e5 or
d5 obviously this e-file hopefully being
used in conjunction with the b-pawn is
where black is gonna get counter play
sometimes the knight moves from c6 to a5
and indicee for supported by the
protection of the rook but I don't
disagree that it feels like white has
gotten a good version of what is this
sort of carries attack against the
knight or four seven again with the
early extended g4 because I actually
don't think that white has issues
castling short or long here I think that
I'm skeptical that blacks counter play
on the Kings side can amount to much and
if white decides he doesn't want the
race okay looks like Grichuk does he
could have done that as well but so now
the question for castles is which pawn
do you want to advance do you want to
push the F pawn where you're trying to
hopefully create an eventual opening
into D
by undermining the light squares or are
you gonna look to get things tactical
quickly with either a 5 or g 5 I like
him people I mean another thing that at
some point White has Robert if black
just keeps the King in the center is an
eventual Knight hop into d5 even at the
risk of it being a sacrifice in some of
these positions right so the time being
taken on the clock combined with just
our general feel of how we look at the
structure this doesn't look like it was
the best Scheveningen for the Polish
fighter if he had to choose his Sicilian
so I'm completely with you I mean
actually really to me more than anything
the clock is telling the tale I agree
with you that I like White's position
for sure yep and now black has a tough
choice because if you take on that for
the bishop takes up four there's a clear
pressure on the d6 pawn and the e4 pawn
will be even easier to protect because
if this e five pawn is removed the rook
you come to d4 follow up with a second
we're coming to D file and there goes d6
not to mention that for pawn it for
Bishop before E 5 is an added threat in
the center and it plays b5 so white
could consider playing f5 to play for
you know g5 and just more expansion but
of course the idea for black is played
before and hit on e4 so before or Queen
to b7 both look quite tempting for black
can we play g5 for white here well
actually I'm not entirely certain how
black when I guess you take on g5 and
once the pawn to g5 happens but Knight
to h5 yeah heading three square yeah
that's what I was highlighting as you
said both f4 and g3 I think white might
still be a teeny bit better there anyway
but I would be against forcing the night
off of f6 and rather find a way to use
the d5 square right away I like I like
this trade Robert before pushing f5
because one of the common mistakes that
less experienced players make in these
structures showing it on the analysis
board in like a knight ourf is that if
you played a5 and close the structure
now a trade on d5 is not nearly as
strong regardless of how black takes it
with the bishop or the night because
with lack of pressure against the e pawn
the structure is actually very safe for
black and this Bishop is not as bad as
it looks because it'll eventually get
out from E
bye-bye trading on d5 first while
there's still tension on e5 and that's
gonna make this whole position a lot
harder for black to defend with the open
e-file yeah I definitely agree with that
and another idea to throw in is now well
not anymore well still possible but I
was going to say rook C one followed by
pawn c4 was certainly something to
consider
yeah it so taking five right away I
think okay black can't castle here
because Bishop takes d5 pawn t5 d6 that
wins the rook on a8 that's why you went
like c8 and the question becomes well is
white really going to take this many 5
and enter opposite colored bishops or
just sustain that pressure there and say
and there H was a very good move saying
if you Castle kingside I'll immediately
go g5 I don't care that the pawn it
breaks open your kings so this is also
the right ideas to sustain the pressure
because the advantage of this light
square bishop that black doesn't have is
actually better here everyone as long as
the bishops remain on the board while
White has the bishop here not in the
obstacle bishop structure after a move
like g5 coming a typical shot for white
is to put the bishop on h3 and remove
the rook from this NVC file there's also
ideas of Bishop before Bishop a5 to do
the same but again looking at the clock
looking at the way Robert has kind of
described white space advantage here I'm
really liking white adding black needs
to try to get a queen to c4 try to get
the ladies off the board do something to
change where this game is headed because
if white gets g5 and Bishop out to this
light square diagonal I think we have
problems we got we got problems if we're
black yeah no I'm in Bishop b4 to f5 was
actually a really smart idea as well
because that kicks the rope from CA and
also temps black to play g6 but you
really don't want to play g6 with a
potential King side on saw happening so
another idea Danny is well with in tune
with bishop before it's like pawn c3
bishops he do Queen e4 and trying to get
on that diagonal if black is the castle
now I'm tempted to play g5 I guess the
point after g5 can black really get away
with it I mean gg5 I'm pondering
there's no way you're going to take that
right the H foil is just too much yeah
that looks really sketchy and if you
don't take and played Bishop e7 then I'm
really tempted to play Bishop takes e5
pawn t5g
and just try to expose your light
squares so this is what the idea we
talked about I mean even just if if
Bishop d7 play Bishop h3 gain a tempo
and say well didn't she just lose a
couple moves and and my attack rages on
and here he goes he plays g5 we have the
property
our first hype donation in the game of
the day today thank you books are nice
we love you a little bit a little bit of
price phone increase for these players
here on the quarterfinals we see all
1500 of you in chat we love all of you
we're also watching the chess TV shad
just letting you know that we see you
because sometimes it's like you know you
have to acknowledge your kids if they're
jumping off the couch or they won't stop
jumping off the couch I love it I love
g5 I like your idea I like taking and
going for g6 but I just feel that Bishop
h3 and then eventually an assault on the
white squares is good enough yeah no
you're you're definitely out wrong
accent g6 right away might be a good
move as well because you don't want to
take with a knight on g6 Bishop takes g7
coming and if you take with the pond
that I could just throw my bishop in the
e6 right away Bishop h3 d6
so he might be considering g6
immediately I'm fishing before played
well why not by force why rush anything
you can just consume make you probably
and I think he's gonna go for your idea
I think he likes the idea of playing g6
he goes before taking but probably just
as good you could even play Bishop takes
e5 now and then Bishop back to f3 if
you're reeling into pawns as Yassir
would be okay Queen c4 eventually comes
but it's gonna be too little too late
I'll be I'll be shocked if the Queen's
come off exactly and that this is just
really ugly not a great start here for
young Christoph looks like he's he's
gonna be going down I mean is just 15
seconds to defend a position like this
with the king of the center not everyone
your thing
rookie one was pretty funny moved
because he was tempting black Castle
kingside which would just walk right
into mates oh right I mean he can go
rookie 3 to c3 that's something I would
certainly consider you know there are
several good operative be three can
always be played any plays c3 certainly
not the first move they can to mind as
well it's clear by what I was just
saying I really thought work III
Internet
rook into the game was another good
option but I guess there's no rush he is
much much better here now black is now
before at least gives black count it I
was sitting here and I think what's the
way to wiggle in and I actually don't
like that move I think grishnack was
missing an opportunity to perhaps play
Bishop h3 Robert and then Queen a5 and
sort of right the wrong of this battery
get the Queen in front of the bishop to
assault the light square so okay I think
why it's still just much much better but
I don't feel like these last several
moves have really made much progress for
Grichuk right he's probably gonna take
on e5 play rook c1 c4 that's really
where he's gone so right now we're
seeing one will be blade okay Queenie to
Sam exactly yeah you can just place c4
now yeah see force a great move it
points out the pin and and we have our
first pin --mode of the day use it use
that pin baby and now his rook can start
infiltrating work c6 is always possible
I guess d5 is hanging here
wait so Queen d5 25 was a pawn I don't
disagree I don't know why he didn't take
it it's hard to find it here comes
Bishop e6 followed by F file problems
I'm guessing rooks can't go Brooke c7
you just hang your rope so I'm not
trying to pull a cardiac in and hang my
review not yet
but only 10 seconds so I mean okay
you're here you can take a four white
rook c2 or before was a nice little
Intermezzo but he's down to four seconds
so you gotta give due to credit that
this game has lasted as long as it has
given the tough position he's been in
for forever here comes the Rebekah's
e-file fighting Ritchie - look see - oh
it hurts it hurts and we have our first
decisive result of the day in favor of
the Russian I say spam some you say
emotes spam some me most spam some emo
there you go so critic strikes first the
next game has begun apparently it just
didn't automatically pop up for me but
there we go we have an Italian neither
one of these guys speaks Italian as far
as I know either so that's that's our
first unique awkward thing of the day I
don't know if that's the first awkward
thing of the day but it won't be the
last
and you're not running it you're
bringing this
back to your mom texted me again about
your name oh you gotta you you leave her
out of this dance so you can do to
spending some time here but this is such
a typical position I mean this is you
know you you see this all the time and
okay granted it's five-minute time
control and you have time to you know
waste 20 seconds early on or in this
case 24 seconds on that move but didn't
feel necessary I mean night if one is
one of those move you should just know
especially if you're an Italian player
right you you eight five is not all the
rage but it's very popular at the
highest level so okay still he's up on
the clock now with the white pieces
slightly better is can't play d4 at any
moment black can always you know this is
why repeats played wasn't black can
always leave this pawn on d4 you don't
actually have to capture yeah you can't
can't capture because you're ready to
pressure this eforp on especially with
the mover PA played so I don't think
white is in a rush to play this d4 move
you play h3 and slowly maneuver before
eventually making that push though yeah
I mean Bishop e6 for black can always be
met by Bishop b5 just avoiding the trade
pinning the knight on c6 threaten to
compromise the pawn structure on the
Queen side and allowing d4 to happen
nonetheless so he did play h3 and yeah
this is not as tactical as the first
game but due to six - you know his
typical repertoire and not really going
crazy and it's interesting about from
Griffith Danny he's playing a five in
this one which he does play in classical
chess but we also know him to be quite a
talented Sicilian player so you know
we'll be interesting to see what he
sticks with yeah yeah he's playing
quickly overall given that like you said
the Sicilian is maybe his his most
preferred weapon again we know that
Grichuk is one of these guys who's
always prepared I don't think you and I
have ever had a post match interview
with him where he didn't do some type of
preparation right so maybe we'll ask him
if this continues to be a pattern if
it's something he specifically felt that
he could he could use against you on
Christoph with success as black
yep and I just saw a great comment in
the and the twitch chats I gotta bring
it up slice says mob boss and half face
coming to a theater near you that is a
pretty accurate description of what
we're you know we're seeing on the
cameras but you know I honestly like
Chris jokes Erica I think it looks fresh
and well do too now I get like a cult
yeah third of his face so we're losing
him a little bit there but in this you
know for the game itself rookie one
played okay I like this he's being
deliberate he's not forcing d4 and
that's something that I think less
experienced players really struggle with
they know that d4 is possible and so
they want to play it as quickly as they
can because it's a strike in the center
but look at this what happened now so
I'm after take on d7 the Queen there it
does now before there's not as the same
pressure that black had and centers on
the other lines you've kicked this night
away from c6 d4 is better protected
there's no light squared bishop on c4
that can be hit by a pawn d5 move so d5
ever happens but just go see five
exactly right you don't have to deal
with the tactics in that square so yeah
look at dude just going for the f5
square he can't go there right just yet
because watch see Kenny Knight f5 Knight
takes a five-night f5 and if you play
Knight takes d4 does queen g4 that's a
tactical a very common tactical pattern
you should be aware of in regards to
this double attack on g7 combined with
the discovered check Fred this is a
something that brings back nightmares
for many right you can lose a lot of
blitz games by just not being aware of
that coming tactics oh I agree with you
I think Knight f5 is possible I like
your point that the reason why it's so
important to note that d5 is something
black would like to play but can't
really hear because of e5 is that if
black doesn't change the structure just
to quote nimzowitsch and and and make
yessir unhappy right I mean you just
have a better Center for white whenever
white can maintain a structure like this
the pawns are keeping blacks pieces at
bay and so strategic strategically you
would believe that White's gonna have
the better middle game right so that's
why Robert is highlighting the desire to
push d5 for black if you could change
the structure to something like this you
be thrilled the problem is you can't
because D 5 will always be met by e 5
some just wanted to highlight that
instructive point because I think as you
look at the structure sometimes people
are like why are they making these move
what is the plan for either side right
and and so when you see white having a
better center there's a reason why black
would like to change that structure but
here what is really making that
difficult to do yep and you know Queen
d3 also helps support 9 to 5 because d5
now the knight will still be protected
on f5 right that you know d5 was an idea
to dislodge the knight but actually
after Knight a5 now I would take with my
knight we take back with your knight and
I'd like Queen takes a5 even and
sacrifice my cream for Knight and rook
and say that your pawn d4 is weak you
have a pin on the first rank I think
black has more than enough compensation
in the line like that would be one line
to see I just showed it on the analysis
board and speaking of your analysis got
to give a shout out to Diamond member
Pino 7 to 4 and the chess TV chat who
says for any new players wanting to
learn just listen to GM Hess's
commentary he's one of the best you get
some love I appreciate that you know I
do my best not always saying the right
thing but trying my hardest so well here
White's gonna have a tough decision to
make I'm gonna guess you're not gonna
capture on e4 and any sort of opening of
the structure training the e4 the D pawn
here black gets active that's got to be
a favorable transition for black okay
maybe maybe in the end there's something
with East six you got to watch out for
but that's a good example of what Robert
was saying White has an advantage black
wants to change the structure which is
what dude is trying to do with this
knight 94 but yeah Grichuk is gonna wave
the finger and say no soup for you I am
not opening the D file I love this move
Knight h5 by the way I just got a little
excited and I strive had actually when
IG sticks is a good response I was gonna
save that from Knight age 5 there were
some threats of rook takes e4 sacrifices
to get that Queen in g3 and try to made
on the g7 square so instead black plays
Knight g6 was it which is smart move you
can play c5 is black at some point but
you don't you know that is good to sort
of break open the center a lot of that
Bishop move life from this diagonal but
you need to make sure your king is safe
before you start playing over there
sword in the Queen side centers 96 is a
very nice
move you take on g6 take back with a
pawn it looks like you're getting a bad
pawn structure for black but you gain
the tempo on this night on h5 and the
real problem for white is this d4
centralized square so you know it's it's
a gaming a superior pawn structure on
the kingside compromise pawns action for
black but actually allows lots of play
can use the F file as well so Knight f3
returns to protect d4 and says your men
on g6 actually isn't that great of a
piece but I mean of course see if I was
gonna be the move that you got your
undermine of no and justify this strong
night but there could be tactics right
you got to watch out for things like
Bishop takes h6 because the f6 squares
under fire as long as you leave this
night on h5 I don't think Bishop takes
a6 works right now but okay if takes
takes takes e4 it's a little tricky but
the point is you're just trying to be
aware of the potential tactical pressure
here the white has and it might may need
to look to do something like that since
black finally did get this c5 move and
he is gonna start changing the structure
in ways that we've been saying he wants
to do for sometime you may have just
uncovered a brilliancy I don't know if
it works but Bishop h6 z h6 rookie 424
and Queen III was what I was thinking he
just sat on e4 way I was gonna say the
whole thing doesn't work as I was
looking for the knight f6 fork but that
wouldn't work as long as my Queen was
hanging but your Queen e3 is really the
key point that Queen takes h6 could be a
threat we're not gonna see it happen
because Sasha settles on the exchange
sacrifice on e4 but that was an
interesting idea there with this Queen
e3 idea Robert yeah I know when Pino
loves you so much things like that yeah
I don't know if it would have panned out
but this looks a little bit suspicious
for white because yeah you're going from
the attack
I feel like black has the exchange and
the compensation here I I don't see the
attack breaking through enough on the
the g7 square okay I guess from a
practical perspective though White has
even more problems yeah the clock I just
realized is actually greatly in bishops
favor once again
yeah why yeah I mean just the sacrifice
here for due to you know it's
speculative
you are down at full exchange you do
certainly have counterplay and Bishop
takes h6 is something that what
continues to have to keep an eye on by
the same time
well material is material and with no
immediate checkmating threats
okay the b7 pawn yeah that might be
another useful pawn to snag but you know
that I don't think it's enough for to
maintain equality I think black is just
better look at that Queen CL he
maneuvered it there's the b7 would be
protected and yes the Queen Justice on
e4 but now you gain the tempo for black
you can make it more useful moving it
doesn't d3 so okay for Falls forgot
about that pawn on it yeah you love d3
to open up the bishop on b6 but you
wonder if he missed a four so okay the
knight comes back to g3 so hard to tell
with griffix kind of stone stone focus
there right he's got quite the poker
face rook aid just you know take the a
pawn that's gotta be good pretty good
and that is how you use your rook when
you're up the exchange so make sense
rook takes is also threatening Brooke in
one chat given that F 2 is under fire
take me to write I guess just take me to
Brooke a one would be met by blocking
with some sort of piece on e1 so take B
to first and now how do you make use of
your rooks you get them on open files
now we're gonna start to see tactics
happened something with both rooks on
the D file right something wicked this
way blows as far as blacks pieces go and
then white only has four seconds to
figure out the tactics Bishop d4 here
would have been good because Knight take
single Queen e5 check and you pick them
back this is a good decision by three
seconds left you have to you have to do
something something magical has to
happen quickly but a nice simplification
there from grishnack I think just to
relieve the pressure he's sort of
relying on the fact that his opponent
doesn't have enough time to figure out
this complicated situation yeah but
Knight f6 check was a threat which is
why D 5 was played how did it look at
the clock one second he barely got that
move off in time and who oh and he
doesn't get the next one off until him
shaking his head he's frustrated a
little bit frustrated but I'm sure he'll
I'm sure he'll relax and and find his
rhythm here
I'm very soon as the next game started
speaking of relaxing we pointed out that
we have to point out that the anagram of
Judas full name is AD jazzy fork nuts
which is probably what his name would be
if he was you know maybe a jazz you know
jazz bar singer wouldn't you know had a
different career path so add jazzy fork
nuts currently needs to rebound and get
back in this Thank You mr. Mike line for
doing something good with what we pay
you for your time for coming up with
that out of anagram very clever can
always trust my client he also was busy
messaging me saying that Khrushchev
reminded of Clint Clint Dempsey the
American soccer player yeah well we've
had a million different references in
regards to what exactly grishnak looks
like and we just had our first big
donation because of it liquid egg
product coming through with a thousand
bit saying let's restore griffix hair
I'm almost afraid to open up the door of
what I'm about to do but you know I'm
gonna have to throw out the Photoshop
contest we've had things like he looks
like he just escaped from you know it
just will have a Shawshank Redemption
reference you have recovering from you
know some sort of therapy I don't know
right what exactly or or he could just
star in every Russian World War two
movie that was ever made so yeah Grichuk
Krishna coming through with the style
the style conversation today yep and
he's also coming through with the chest
with the co-lead and this approach by
Duda is different than the first game
because it spawns on g5 which makes f4
both easier and harder to play now why I
say it makes it hard to play as well of
course is trade this just happened
yeah but easier because it's encouraging
me to do so I don't want to just put you
know have this backward out f-pawn so I
want to get rid of it and open up a line
from my rook but from that point of view
to though I mean this is a little more
active than black last had in this
Sicilian that we saw in Game one yeah
and I mean rook is partly to blame
because he went b3 Bishop b2 and so that
invites black for a clear counter on the
Queen side right he just did
exactly what you'd expect him to do a a
five a four you can't play B for his
white because that gives night the night
to see Foursquare which is just
extremely vital yeah and so you know
he's gonna eventually take on b3 he just
might push Queen on 87 first and say you
know you might get made it pretty
quickly I really know I came this as an
adjustment to the last time did they had
the Sicilian just everything you
highlighted now now Grichuk retreats to
try to get rid of that strong night but
honestly why I can just stare the
night's down and and play chicken cuz
white really doesn't want to trade and
allow these double D pawns that open up
the darks were fish 27 and he may have
to do it because this knight on e5 is so
annoying but this is the type of
structure black really wants to get
against this big pawn storm on the Kings
side that for those who've been with us
the whole time you saw a grishnack used
successfully in game 1 but here I feel
like Grichuk is off to a much better
much better chance you mean do that I
agree sure oh sorry Duda I'm sorry black
yes I'm sorry
yeah confusing why yes well I actually
think restrict position is also quite
interesting I'm you know Queen a7 is
sort of the obvious move threatened to
play politics b3 quina to check and
whether that leads to mate is another
story but for example Queen a7 you can't
take on e5 because after politics e5
you have to move your knight to say f3
and then I take on b3 Queen a to check
and Bishop a3 you and you're not going
to be very happy with the consequences
so you know it's a little bit deep but
it's a very forced sequence of events so
he just take on b3 first and plays 27
now saying if you go a3 but not your
certainly again not taking me on e5 to
open up my Bishop to that a3 pawn so
that's really a tough situation because
this black king is stuck in the center I
think if white gets another move Krisha
can play Knight d4 as an option just to
close down the Queen side and they
rewrite that Bishop from g2 to f1 and
hit the b5 on yep and like I said this
King on
Eata to g7 but that also looks very
risky because there's a bishop on b2
staring down the diagonal I'm starting
to like White's position more honestly I
I don't see the immediate attack for
black and you really need something
quick
to justify your expose King and the fact
that you will not be able to cancel I
mean Knight takes D 3 Queen D 3 pawn
before or something that just closed
down the Queen side when white goes a 4
yo and closes closes off all potential
access points alright yeah so it looks
like despite the more active appearance
and the the fact that white has lost the
potential pawns form on the dark squares
still still really difficult and the
time management by due to suggest that
you're right that he he's he's still not
happy with his position as black yep so
no I don't even see a good move for
black here you need to keep them there
any five to stop this Bishop on b2 but
you don't really have a useful way to
kind of launch your attack here I think
the overall issue right now if you
wanted to assess how the first few games
have gone okay I mean grishnack is a
really strong chess player and has shown
that to be the case but dude is time
management right in the critical moments
grishnack has been able to take those
extra seconds to play better moves and
and Duda has been in a time scramble for
way too many critical moments than you
would want right and it looks like we
might be headed for another game like
that where he's got to figure out the
mess with no time on the clock
there's Knight f5 work here Knight a5
ef5 b takes f5 both rooks are under
attack by Bishop um b2 is now open to
your 95 I mean this looks at the very
least looks like a tremendous attack to
the Batcave I've gone with the analysis
and I agree in fact you can even just
take e5 and say it forget the rook cuz
once you take on the e father's threats
like Queen to d6 the bishop on e7 is
pinned so he didn't go for it but I
don't think that was a crazy idea at all
in fact I I mean I could see black
actually consolidating a little bit here
I still love this night on before it's
very strong prevents black and going d5
the e5 pawn of course now will you know
we'll be hanging if you do play d5 but
the point is that the Queen side attack
looks like it's completely stopped in
his tracks right and white is regrouping
sucked is about to come either to C or D
you might got a d3 to look for an
exchange sac you might go to c3 which
does two things grabs a c5 but the other
thing is that the b-pawn was potentially
under fire after E 5 Bishop e6 so rookie
3 is like multi-purpose moved there by
Grichuk I like the exchange side ripped
III takes d6 I mean it's really just I
don't know if anything's more tempting
here because you're just getting rid of
this ePHI pawn next regional
me think it looks t6 there might be
Knight takes e5 I was gonna say there's
got to be some sort of tactic that the
do to saw you also have to be careful if
you get too freaky there's this Queen
eyeing the g1 square okay not anymore so
um I was thinking Grichuk has to be
careful of giving his opponent
unnecessary chances but but he can even
just sit here play brook c1 and rook c3
I mean I like the exchange sac from a
positional point of view like you said
really it undermines the e5 pawn and and
turns your dark square bishop into a
monster but when your opponent has less
than a minute do you really need to
change the structure so drastically nope
what about h4 here by the way h4 Bishop
takes g4 Bishop g4 you take Knight takes
d4 Knight d5 which means your Knights
not gonna really come back to f6 I like
it I'm thinking also tempting a lot of
temptation going on here today probably
cuz you took a shower and I just you
know you're feeling really good I do
feel good Danny I you know I was looking
forward to this match so yeah it's just
I like it's maybe you don't need to rush
for from my point of view that you don't
have to play h4 so soon but I think he's
calculating right now seeing what the
consequences are if that capture on g4
does happen had the luxury we talked
about how Grichuk has been such a time
pressure addict in many ways right in a
lot of his matches but have we ever seen
a match where he's been up this much on
time in the first period can't think of
it I can't think of it right and this is
a great move by Duda and very quick
response but Knight d7 both hits the h4
pawn which is one you do want to capture
sometimes you don't want to capture
pawns that are attacking you because it
opens up a new file for the rook right
after Bishop takes h4 you can just throw
that
schibetta g5 and shore up your kingside
but here the Knights also coming to c5
with temple on the Brooklyn III and pawn
on b3 so 95 now it takes on H 75 that's
that I think that was his idea was to
maybe play g5 and open up if you block
the bishop you have 97 but maybe g5
black just takes with the bishop yeah
because that way you stop this like you
said it's 97 yeah we should give up this
H pawn he was really worried about
Knights e5 winning the b3 pawn so he
decided to do this but he's shaking his
head now and looking a little bit
regretful of his actions for the first
time today Thank You chess Bay for not
not gifting for the first time today or
the first time in this channel looks
like 137 times you have done that so
thank you chess Bay everybody remember
you can enter in the raffle to win some
free merch today and remember that if
you do decide you just want some merch
and you don't want to see if you win the
raffle all purchases made during today's
show go directly to the price Fund for
the players so Knight comes back to e3
and into f5 Robert the move you wanted
all along
yep there comes a night I think you
should down away earlier but it's gonna
be a mess now but you can tell by
Grichuk sort of his poise appearance I
mean he his two-minute time advantage
has completely disappeared which is
pretty telling as far as how he feels
about it and now now he's got issues to
figure out by the way in the game chat
on in chess comm you know
Chomsky advised to not play the Sicilian
against Kershaw it's a direct quote he
said two places sailing against Chris
Suga suicide but I mean right now things
are clearly changed in this dynamic here
I mean isn't black just winning all the
pawns and blacks King is quite the
turnaround I mean given that we've this
has been all Grichuk all day so pride
okay Bishop takes you fraud not quite
over yet
I guess Queen a force coming in it was
gonna be made on the a file if you took
e5 he's hoping for Bishop takes a four
was in Queens e4 check would come so
rook takes a for Bishop a to check is
not a huge threat now this is terrible
is every two seconds one sec
and barely makes a move still not sure
how he deals with Bishop a to check or
okay - yeah that that looks like it's
lights out and he lets the clock run out
so where did where did that game go
wrong from the perspective that White
was definitely better in the middle game
at one point but eventually blacks
activity did win out and I think just
giving up this H+ just seemed like a
massive mistake just just a big a big
blunder there yeah I think he led do to
hang in long enough and this is one of
those things when you have both a
spatial advantage your opponent's king
is a weak but there's gonna be some
counter chances you need to land the
knockout blow
you can't just let especially a player
as strong as due to a tactical very
strong tactical player kaylynn hang in
there and we got a stat firm chest kid
by the way that's mr. Mike line dude it
when the game is black against cardiac
in until game 17 so he wins
remember when you remember that match
Danny white was winning like 12 games in
a row
no not like white won 12 games in a row
and shout out to all the subs coming in
that's right a raffle is for subs only
this particular time around so we really
appreciate all the support and all that
all that is coming our way for these
players today and and all the viewers
whether you're on chest comm TV or
twitch TV slash chess chess eclis
inclined hanging out in the chest TV
chat title player and streamer all right
well we have a not exactly the same type
of structure we had last time but we do
have another Italian I like this move
Knight g5
I don't even care if h6 kicks it back
I'll go honey badger on this and just
play h4 I won't even care we always
leave the night there and go for sac sac
made on the H file I figure that's what
you would want to do but you're not
really gonna be able to sack anything
but I'm not surprised at all that you
want to play well the ideas yeah it
wouldn't be good and one of the main
reasons is that black is probably gonna
develop the Bishop to g4 here at some
point which will close the Queens
entryway to the Kings side whether it's
met by f3 or by moving
so Duda trying to figure out how he
wants to justify that last move 95
sometimes you can do it with f4 but to
me in that position that would
immediately invite Knight G for
discovering on the bishop on on e3 and
the night on g5 so ok so he does go for
h4 but I'm guessing grishnack plays the
move Bishop c4 to induce f3 even if you
just come back to say d7 after that the
point is you've really just made it
harder for white to quickly bring pieces
to the Kings side and f4 is still not an
option in a lot of these positions
because of the Knight to g4 the dark
squares are weak ya know you know I'm H
was on a bad move I want to you know say
that it's not like you've weakened
anything you just pushed a pawn forward
I just don't feel like there's a real
attack happening quite yet especially
because black has firm control over the
g4 score in order to play g4 which you'd
love to do you have to play f3 first am
I playing f3 first as you mentioned the
Queen now will not have the same access
to the H file that said why not just
like Queen d2 Castle queenside and
figure out what to do with that night
like right now yeah like we need you
when I can't I can't take your night
because after night h7 you have g6 or I
was worried about removing my queen but
I get maybe you could even just castle
long and say that I don't need mate
without with my Queen on this d1 h5
diagonal maybe I just have the H file
right right so but Mike is not taking
this night on g5 anytime soon and 94 is
a good move because you need to gain
some sort of activity okay just sit
cramped and allow white to continue with
Queen e2 Castle queenside g4 etcetera so
thank you for now this piece can go to
the east 6 square if you'd like not that
it really does anything putting your 96
it's not threaten to take on g5 but
there it is b5 was the other up now the
downside of playing b5 so the upside is
you gain more space perhaps you can
start continue pushing your pawns 85
before the downside is by pushing your
pond you might leave behind some
weaknesses so you know if the position
changes from a tactical nature to a
positional one you might have
overextended on the Queen side a little
bit right it's always white is to
eventually maybe
take on d4 for example use the d5 square
okay Christic trying to stop access to
the d5 square now is c6 but ya know
that's a good point the consequences of
overextending your pawns too quickly if
it doesn't remain just a race position
for checkmate but I I'm getting nervous
for I just I get nervous from the
perspective if I'm white and I just
leave this night hanging on g5 mainly
because I'm just biased to the fact that
normally we need a quick entry to the
Kings side in order to justify it so the
problem with leaving pieces like that on
pre for too long is at some point you
still think it's poisoned but your
opponent decides they're willing to risk
capturing it so you got to be really
careful yep and the 9 g5 actually blocks
your own progress right you won't play
g4 g5 that night was not there you put
that night on f2 for example right or G
if I would come immediately and that's
exactly what you wanted so much so that
may be why should consider we're
treating the night and playing g4 and g5
because now that you have this h6 pawn
to try to pry open the H file right yep
and so you know you got to keep them in
there for at least for the time being
with the f3 pomp square being under
attack but he was king me once and go c3
perhaps yeah this Knight you don't
really want to go c3 because once you
play C 3 B 4 is even more impactful for
a black although B 4 right away and
what's the problem with that I don't
think any problem and neither does
grishnack plays before and somehow this
is despite Knight g5 being played all
the way back on what was it move 7 move
8 black is the one with an attack and
the more you get distracted here you
still have a knight hanging on g5 unless
you deal with it Diamond remember chess
coach net and a streamer well known in
the chest community says if Duda wins
this match he'll break the internet he
might but sometimes plays are meant to
be broken haven't you ever seen wreck-it
Ralph - I personally have not no but I
trust you on this one so ok you can't
take on a4 because then Knight takes up
7 but you can play Bishop d7 here and
then take a 4 next it's not like White's
going d3 to protect that pawn so Bishop
d7 you play g4 Bishop takes a 4
then maybe Knight takes f7 check
followed by g5
it's looks good for black I know I don't
believe in it from my point of view
okay I'm not as confident in that move
so what did I just take that pawn on d5
so pawn to e5 Bishop d7 okay Bishop d6
first but now ninety-four happens with
tempo hmm yeah that actually seems like
a good transition for do two if you can
use the e4 square g4 comes now
eventually the night comes to you for
and we get g5 that we've wanted all
along to pry open the H file even at the
cost of the a pawn I'm liking this more
for Duda than I was before
forget the a pawn now we now we can turn
this back into a race put the knight on
e4 and punch g5 through yeah and you
can't go Bishop d7 ever extend Knight f5
comes and I'm 30 nice sacks all over the
board Knight f5 may come anyway because
if you take on that five I take with me
G pawn and all of a sudden the G file is
open for my rooks so okay wouldn't 94
that makes perfect sense
can't take on d5 to the fisherman d6
hanging oh this this looks yeah the
bishop is under fire and and okay g5 can
be met by h5 and temporarily keep it
closed that's a that's a kind of a key
defensive strategy if you have a pawn
that can be undermined everyone but but
if white plays h5 first and stops that
then g5 comes there's nowhere for black
to avoid the tension and thank you
claims are gonna start opening up what
if you put h5 I make it's they're
playing b3 is black just trying to get
that quick counter play on the Queen but
even so if you play b3 I mean give you a
couple moves I guess I mean take with
the Bishop a4 exactly I'm trying to go
bish from a3 over p8 and five like b3
here immediately push that Palmer
so b3 if you take with the palm of
meteor a go Bishop b4 + f6 and nice
Bishop on a 2 you've got I agree I just
feel like the nature of the game has
become much more of a race position than
it was before and you have to be happy
about that if you're white you were just
getting outplayed on the Queen side
right right for sure and he goes up six
because he's not concerned he says that
White's attack is too slow right my
shirt I totally worth that now Knight
takes f6 is an option I you could play a
4/4 black you can avoid b3 again I
really would not discount
he plays a for first now threatening b3
and there it is so you can't take on b3
with the punks that for eight takes me
three you're getting may have done the a
file I say that very confidently because
I see that immediately a threat would be
rook a one okay one check so you cannot
afford to open up the that file there
for sure so what can you do Knight d6 is
sure you can take on d6 right away but
then maybe you take on b3 and well and
took right away okay didn't want to take
up c2 first but this looks like wishful
attack for white yet was just too slow
especially I mean sorry I got distracted
by griffix aggressive camera positioning
it is he leads it and we now have a view
of his of his bicep and a rather a
rather sexy neckbeard going on I think
you know but no III I think that White's
attack is too slow unless you could have
found a way to maneuver the knight in on
those light squares and since he didn't
and settled on trading tonight back to
really liking black ok c3 do you have
this pin and looking to do it with six
seconds left
yep I mean a3 is as tempting as they
come for a3 looks good rookie Rookie
eight what's he gonna do I was gonna say
you could even just trade Queens here
put the rook on the second ranked rook
everyone though just I don't know if I
trust us for okay Brooke a she's a nice
move just yeah liking everything we're
getting the g4 pawn that's where he's
coming after yes
but simply treat you for what the bishop
right yeah then take h5
so d6 I guess you just gonna rip da you
don't you're on time to push that pawn
but you'd really like to be able to
start making progress the jury some of
your D pawns yeah okay what's this
nice move rook c8 check who's forcing
the king over now the real King enter
the game cuz rook do you want would be
mate so Brooke c6 check one of those
little cute inner Rizzo's that gain a
key tempo you it didn't you invent those
definitely not but I like to take
advantage on that's for sure alright
well we have a three to one lead so
Grisha currently taking advantage of his
opponent right now but still plenty of
time left 45 minutes roughly in the
five-minute portion will try to give
Grichuk a heads up that he eventually
leaned in at this point there was
nothing we can do to change the fact
that he that he's given us an
interesting view of his body and that's
something you could never get if you
were watching over the more classical
chess oh you're welcome twitch and chess
TV so I just saw him twitch from Armenia
Eagles come on
you are alpha zero Robert gotta love our
talk gotta love him joining the twitch
chat but no I'm certainly not alpha zero
that would be interesting though let's
see this game d4 square that's really
where it's all about d4 d5 black is
trying to remove the guard of the D
force what pawn by taking on f3 and
white on the other hand is trying to
kick this night from d5 and so that Y
could play d5 himself it should have
three Queen f3 Knight d2 b4 certainly an
option trying to head to the c2 square
he plays Bishop h5 and oh so quickly I
think he's realizing that he's having
most of his difficulties have been on
the clock honestly even when he's had a
chances to stay in the game he well but
it's also been his first change away
from the Sicilian right and you
the comment of course earlier that the
one-and-only got a comp scheme the chat
was advising not to play the sicilian
against Sasha crook so you heard it
there right so maybe maybe due to saying
tired of being worse in the Scheveningen
and I'm gonna mix it up here with a
little little old-school Russian defense
little Petrov honestly I think blacks
position is fine here I agree I know I
think it was a good decision
it's what I'm saying yeah I was
suggesting as Sam Adams good decision so
well you did say play the Russian
defense and playing it against the
Russian player now always very smart you
know I've seen car yakking on the white
side of the petrov before not always
very pretty for Fabiano Caruana
so there's a candidate's reference it
wasn't really at all that was many moons
ago we don't remember that anymore
because now Fabiano is playing for the
world championship so we've forgotten
all about that candidates now that was a
pretty one-sided getting affair so yeah
okay black sitting up thinking here
saying how do i reinforce this knight on
d5 and he goes Queen d7 bingo Brooke d8
next yeah you don't really want to
capture on c3 you don't mind it right
Knight takes c3 BC 3 has benefits for
both sides for white you're not your
default pawn is clearly protected for
black you say well that pond and c3
actually can become a target you have
these potentially hanging pawn structure
with C and D pawns can be vulnerable in
this particular setup I think white is
happy to allow that because d4 is going
to be difficult to find people you need
for for white well then you're really
risking overextending on the Kings side
and leaving yourself too exposed and on
the other hand playing g4 you're no
longer worried about that pin d4 feel
safer you can follow it up with Bishop
to b5 and get your Knight to e5 I was
gonna say you could play Bishop g2 as
well yep for sure
but I was I'm always trying to highlight
to anticipate the instructive point
you're making that's what I do
but while you're over there you know
dropping chest knowledge and I was gonna
say he goes for it because if you can't
sack on g4 I actually like the idea if
you can defend the Kings side by
bringing more minors there sometimes you
can justify these types of pawn advances
but you're right it is
super double-edge right sometimes
pushing that Jeep on is a move you wish
you could have back later
but if you're just play Bishop g2 okay
you think he'll go for your Bishop e5 at
night Bishop e5 and 95 it's the risk of
that is then you're really going for the
tactics but now you've got the light
squares and a potentially naked King
yeah I think Bishop g2 is the safer
safer route yeah it's it's honestly just
a smarter move because Bishop b5 has a
one move threat of Knight f6 which black
can stop with f6 or Bishop f6 so putting
the fisherman GCU certainly is wiser you
know in response here blacks putting the
set with bishop on d6 which is a great
diagonal right there's no G three pawns
of blunting that bishop so the bishop
wendy6 stares in both directions there's
the h2 square
always keep an eye out on that okay very
difficult to get to but very importantly
the f3 pawn that's a weakness that white
will need to work a little bit to defend
c4 gain space now you play c5 or d5 your
queen can come to b3 at any moment the
spatial grab is certainly nice for white
and problem for black because look at
the two different pawn islands right
you've got the h3 F pawns and then a
through C pawns you don't really know
what to do with them what's the best
setup you can play b69 a5 but i don't
know doesn't feel necessarily ideal you
can play move your knight and play pawn
to c6 but then you can see a piece
coming to the be filed and pawn to c5
keeping that punim b7 backwards so you
it's hard to actually figure out the
exact way for black to make progress in
that side of the board I would assume
that you want to put this pawn on d6 but
I just think that it also creates some
difficulties with a white plain d5 at
some point maybe the c6 square is moment
bull so you know every pawn move makes a
concession you may place b6 I think
that's the best decision in this case
pushing the pawn makes the c6 and AC
squares possible possibilities for white
to start infiltrating but I think it's
the ultimately the right decision here
specifically with white pawns setup the
way they are and stopping white from
ever
playing pawn to c5 yeah and you made a
great point about the hanging pawn
structure talking about how normally
these are the types of weaknesses that
are targeted on open files but because
the structure is different ok now we're
about to see the structure change but
really important to recognize that if
maybe this black pawn on c7 was over on
the e-file before c5 was played and
black could actually put a couple pieces
on the open lines that would be a more
typical way we see the hanging pawns
target but Duda was unable to get that
sort of thing here which is why we see
him play the defensive-minded b6 and and
now he's probably just gonna be worse
because I'm assuming Knight takes e5 is
not gonna be met by capture back but
Bishop takes e4 and that that looks
actually really really tricky for black
white gets the bishop pair and the open
position is definitely gonna favor white
yeah requires some calculation Knight
takes d5 Bishop takes e4 90s g4 in
exchange sacrifice right but doesn't go
for Plus Queen d5 and yeah that looks
Devin looks scary along this diagonal
now black would return the favor we
talked about not taking back the obvious
piece if white took c6 here everyone
black would play Bishop takes g2 and
just be completely winning on the light
squares so we take trade and now I must
guessing d5 is gonna fall oh yeah
immediately not sure this is good for
one I'm not sure Daz I was gonna say not
it not a huge future for these pawns
though I mean they're they're probably
just gonna to be traded or become
targets well it's a queen blunder Queen
shame on us for thinking we'd have a
positional chess you know lesson coming
instead we have hey make sure you take
your you take your you drink your coffee
or 5-hour energy or whatever you're into
right if you're sponsored by Red Bull
then I guess you got a drink it he shook
his head smiled it laughed it off shook
his head I mean put his hand over his
mouth his hand over his forehead wiped
his face I think I just you know pretty
much reenacting it with my words there
what just happened that was gonna say
could you describe that again well I see
a great response from where'd he go
Oh lost it oh here whoo
four four four no reaction from griffix
chin yeah how many actions from griffix
chin you know he's working on that I've
actually talked him he's working on some
chin movements but that's a whole nother
show the seriously though that was a
really disappointing loss for do two
mainly from the perspective that he was
he he had played really well as black
right he yet he had played he switched
things up Robert to the Petrov right he
had gotten the positional battle he was
looking for no longer getting outplayed
in the sharp Sicilian as maybe he was
reading shot and saw what gata Kamsky
said I don't know right but it felt like
Duda was in the best potential position
he's been as black so far okay he won
that other game but you know he wasn't
really better yeah then you just blunder
your queen so that hurts it hurts i I
understand why he went Queen a4 just to
you know poke at the Queen side and stop
the pawn in his tracks and the a file
and but it's Hong Queen I mean that was
unbelievably tried to justify a move
positionally and then like there was I
had a really nice chess coach as a kid
who never said like that's a bad move
and be like there's checkmate in one and
some kid suggests hang in a queen he'd
be like that's an interesting idea did
you consider this other idea right
that's so like there's no way to justify
a queen a queen blunder I tried I mean
that just caught me by surprise there
du-de du-de doesn't do two looks like a
lady gone bye-bye doo dodoo de doesn't
like his ladies I don't know that was
necessary I just I can't believe it so
he's he looked like he in a nice
position but okay we got to move on and
in this game we see an imbalance in the
position khalaq has he double F pawns
but also has the two bishops because
what has given up the darks for Bishop
at first glance I really like White's
position I say that yes you know having
two bishops is nice for a second I
thought he blew into a queen again with
Bishop f5 but of course that's a Bishop
a5 get Pawnee for it so it's not
actually plunder but I like the strong
center center control for white and
white can consider playing efore f4 and
E 5 just to gain space in the center you
may have to make sure your King is not
on the same diagonal your queen so but
if you this epon we're missing then
Bishop f5 of course
is a big threat and worship decides to
head on over to the g7 square with his
king but I don't think it actually makes
his king you know particularly safe
either
as mentioned f45 is something that
certainly should be on the lookout for
white by playing f4 you do give black
edgy Foursquare permanently so you you
have to consider that really deeply
before just allowing a bishop to park
it's out there but at the same time I
love this spatial grab so what are their
ideas that's white half here I don't see
many you could play f3 and play solidly
that's certainly a possibility but not
as aggressive as at forty five coming
but you're not really in a position
where you're that worried about blacks
attack over on the Queen side you have
this night in front of the B pawn
breaking Russian schoolboy knowledge
meaning black is not okay you can push a
five minute for but black doesn't have a
very dangerous looking attack coming
anytime soon so it means maybe white has
a little bit of time right as I say that
here comes a five but I think a three is
just fine the bishop can tuck itself to
a two and eventually due to likely will
go back for your plan of f4 and you know
you're right if you could play b7 to b5
right now you'd be much happier about
your position but the night m b6 v75
because what you really want here
everyone is b4 not a four right you
don't want to play a four and close off
your your route to get into the kingdom
but and that's probably why he plays
Bishop c7 I think if black has his way
he'll move the knight from b6 and try to
go for B 5 B for some help yeah just
it's really difficult for block to do
that because if you play Knight d7
you're not even threatening b5 because I
could take on b5 when your Bishop on c7
so look at you look at you just you had
your Wheaties I actually just had some
you know protein bars you know might
need some looking a little time the
match here only started an hour later
than his previously his previous match
with cardiac indeed but something about
the way he sort of just rubbed his eyes
and you know obviously not been his
sharpest self blundering the Queen makes
me feel like maybe our young Polish man
is is a little bit more tired in today's
match right now yeah maybe he also
more expectation for himself ash I think
everyone well besides me
but many people thought that correct him
such a heavy favorite now that he got
that win under his belt he said well why
is chris scherk any better than I am in
this format right I've been calling down
3 games early to someone as strong as
Sascha Brooke is clearly not a good
thing he goes at four here which i think
is a good thing and on the other hand he
could have waited because what was
black's next move well you made a good
point that 97 wasn't a threat not even
just cuz b5 wasn't a threat but 95 right
away might have been an interesting
little tactic if you want the bishop
that bed
maybe not but yeah the point is yeah
black is not really in the driver's seat
as far as getting an attack because of
this night just functionally placed in
front of the B point okay like okay what
is black what does like do now anyway
does he put the bishop on c4 is that why
we regret it for yeah that's right he
does it I guess because you need to gain
space for your pieces and that's the
only available square which is actually
why I was about to say before that
perhaps there was a useful waiting move
that white had because Bishop g4
otherwise were met by f3 first and then
f4 but I like this for white nonetheless
the bishop on c7 normally would like to
have any two bishops here I don't the
mission one c7 is now I just completely
blockaded by the whites pawn structure
and I just want to point out that
someone said do to read tip so dude it
looks like he's been studying theory all
day and he probably has yeah because
he's preparing for the Olympia so it
sound like a joke but you know it's very
no it's sorry and obviously these
matches because they're online and
convenient players can literally play
home with no pants on because how would
we know right you know they're they
don't necessarily do the things on a
game day match Robert you usually don't
spend a ton of time studying opening
theory you're doing things to make sure
you're sharp tactically you're doing
other sorts of things to make sure
you're in game shape so if you spend a
lot of time studying and then just turn
on the computer and try to play
high-quality blitz for a few hours you
might be tired yep so and what is this
setup what is look at the night on b6
and the night on g3 did these
let's not get the memo I mean did you
get the memo the TPS letter well I think
he's gonna he's getting the memo now
have played night f12 III I hopefully
this is neither one of these nights is
doing anything special you would love to
find a way if you're white to just make
the play all about the Queen side and
leave this Bishop on chief for like a
bystander right play 93 swing the rook
to c1 maybe try to play d5 and open up
the position and this Bishop on g4 might
just feel like a lost soul over there
well now Bishop takes d5 and 93 plays
itself I like it
okay 93 I guess b5 is what Black's
trying desperately to get in so Queen b3
I was about to say Queen b3 is a nice
inclusion it tags d5 and salves b5 and
that was blacks really only source of
counter play and you have to kind of hop
on your point
the bishop Lindsay forced terrible it's
just a big pond there is actually well
can't protect stop something from going
to eat two or d1 but it's not actually
doing anything yeah so if you could
trade off all the major pieces
descending would be easily winning for
white because that's gonna capture
honestly you could capture in any moment
oh I do too really taking his time
grinding this out and seems to have
found some energy from whatever that
snack is you should just put the rook on
c1 no rush
okay we're take a five right I mean the
only way you blunder this one away is if
you somehow move this knife from c3 and
forget that blacks Bishop can get out on
the e2 square so like Knight a for
Bishop e2 and maybe my he just shook his
head I swear he was just thinking about
9 a 4 and I think he backed up and shook
his head cuz he's like no don't blend
over again and I know that it but I'm
playing playing chess as much as we have
I think we're right about that right it
looks like he was about to play that and
then saw it yep
and I mean roopd 2 was a good move he
could have played you could have taken
on g4 I don't think it's actually a bad
decision to take there it does get rid
of one of your good nights hitting the
d5 square but he's not gonna capture
because if you look at blacks position
you can't she
move your ROK's you need to keep that d5
palm protected hooking and play he's
trying to play for the C file he needs a
protect so Queen b3 going after d5 again
I guess look how what the doctor griffix
position is now that the rook on d2 is
keeping the e2 square carted he was free
to move this Knight regroup to the C
file okay I mean grishnack is shuffling
his king which is frankly a smart
practical decision if you're just worse
at the very least don't get yourself
under time pressure and now black ok
black gets rid of the bad bishop but I
guess white saying look I've won enough
I've got the C file I'm up upon I don't
I don't need the complications anymore
yeah this is just terrible for black I
mean you know the bad best you'll
somehow sneak in and try to win some
pawns but your kings not particularly
safe your b7 pot I mean Knights c-93
hangs the d4 balls I don't want to do
that you can't even play Queen f3
because I can just take it and then go
off to your new F pawn so I love Brooks
e5 because there's a threat of Knight c3
winning d5 I was just gonna say that if
you could you could give up d4 as long
as you get d5 with it you're still in an
easily winning end game right now rook
Seath Oh Brooke C - I think he'll at
some point put the rook on c3 maybe even
play Queen c2 and offer a trade of the
ladies and I play east six as well right
just try to push that e pawn through
okay yeah also looks good Queen Queen
before threatening 27 everyone I mean
he's he's doing well here rook b3 okay
quit me six also very good was rookie
dirty she just took Duda looks like a
lady Duda knows how to use his lady yeah
slithering in Queen to b6 he could take
on b7 don't hang the a4 pawn and all
will be well right yeah you're gonna you
guys so hang on Queen takes d5 Queen a4
night a3 or rook 83 yeah this could be I
mean assuming this finishes in the
direction that it should right now this
feels like the most complete game we've
had by dudas so far in the match would
you agree with that I would definitely
agree that I don't like move b3 just cuz
it makes me feel like my king is the one
safe but okay it's still completely win
and still be winning four do yes
definitely is that actually I'm just the
most complete game by Judah I think is
the most complete game for you by either
play I agree this has been a super high
quality game and now look at this a5
move Karpov is happy
every piece protects every piece Queen
protects the knight Knight protects the
Brook King before King before black
sacrifices the pawn under the bishop
desperately here comes Paul hey James is
another Queen
there was rook b8 check could have been
included there before g2 prefix of seven
is a mate problem isn't it yeah it's
gonna say that's smiles a little bit
he's like well forgot about that one
when I got that second Queen on g1 well
we haven't forgotten we have a we have a
great match here 3,000 of you with us
whether you're on chess TV or twitch TV
slash chess thanks for being here
remember subscribers you can enter in
our raffle today just type whatever the
raffle command is and when some merch
which will be given away during the
three minute portion by the way toward
the end of the stream inner portion is
when we will give away our our merch
today so Robert talk about how big that
win was you're up you're you're down
only 3-1 and you're in a position to
have a successful result as black but
you blunder your queen in one move the
fact that he was able to gather himself
emotionally and strike back and not go
on a full-tilt I mean how big is a win
like that to only be down two games
given where this this could have been
headed before I answer that question I
need to look at this position I know the
watching on f7 let's try to distract
yeah
wait why g6 you need about King e6 I
guess I go key six now I mean what is
sorry I don't even okay you don't answer
my question let's just say it was a big
win for Judah now let's talk about this
position yeah here we go analysis I
thought instead of g6 he could have
played King e6 that way he protects his
Bishop and gets out of the pin at the
same time I'm sure Lord but it's still
really aggressive I mean there's c4 and
Knight c3 coming here this is like a
lolly gambit gone wild x-rated edition
yeah I mean okay Bishop d6 heading for
checkmate
so Queen h4 pawn takes g6 check King
runs to e7 or did I miss again pretty
crazy
materials now even again and whose King
is gonna end up being in more danger I
mean after Queen h4
I mean Queen h4 if you take on g6 I can
even go King e6 how crazy would that be
walk your king away the reason Robert
wants to do that everyone is to try to
use the G foil for the rook Oh King e6
is queen of Sun was made lol king e7 is
what I initially said and Queen f7 is
met by King d8 and my King runs to
shelter and your King on G 1 will become
victim to an immediate attack so don't
blender mate like I did and this is
tough Queen g2 just pontes don't you
again I just put the rook on g8 that's
kind of what I wanted right
well room G is where that bishop takes
e4 HOD then you have Bishop c5 check I
missed that exactly
so if you played Queen g2 perhaps I just
take g6 and open up the H file to hit H
to them yeah looks pretty tempting you
can also mmm reminded by our our stat
boy that in six games we've had no draws
and remember that due to only had one
draw into five-minute person versus
cardiac end so if you want to know why
the Polish fighter 3000 chose that
username due to place himself some
enterprising chest right I mean
seriously this has been two of the most
decisive matches we've ever had and in
the ones that do too has been in whoa
look you won - give me that pawn or
queen would you play what about Dave can
I get rook f8 and get after f2 so rook
f8 I think his idea so rook 8 f8 rook
takes e4 check takes and then your
sacred snack in the exchange yeah but
this what I mean I got the exchange if
I'm black I mean that can't be I can
take g6 there h2 is hanging yep so rook
okay if a seems interesting at least
and in Queen h2 check also Queen h2 King
f1 Brooke a f8 okay Bishu eights you
check first so what if King G - I guess
King G - you just go broke a f8 anyway
and not in time
weird weird position I'm gonna answer
your question earlier I am actually very
impressed that dude handled it together
yeah yeah I know he rebounded very nice
and extremely impressively and he smiled
after that win and I think he's
impressed with himself he's not played
grow shook and any over the board games
that at least not published and to prove
it you can beat one of the world's best
players like that and such a kind of
one-sided and Swift battle very very
impressive and you know showing his
might so here on the black side you know
he's back to having an attack I mean
again I don't know I'm still nervous
about who's King is is in more danger
long-term I feel like Y can play both
Kings you - in king of one but I like
the idea that the Brooks coming to the F
file and it just seems like the
variation you gave we're white
sac the exchange might end up being
forced I mean yeah and is this really
the endgame that white wants down the
exchange no I mean I don't think so and
given the time situation and that we've
we've seen Grichuk be up on time most
the time it feels like we're not crazy
to be believing the yawn he quickly
plays the line that we've been calling
for and Robert once again proven to be a
seer of some kind we're still getting
we're still looking into that everybody
whether Robert has a crystal ball or not
that's that's currently for discussion
what's not for discussion is that Greg
has some guns he's showing off now yeah
now black is no Bishop f4 next and trade
off the bishops this is just good for
black yep
oh wait did I predict this line are you
who got this one right I forget
my track that's all so I'm just you know
okay so just don't get made it is there
anything like you baited hook Bishop f4
Knight c4 check King e6 d5 Drive mm-hmm
so don't don't play Bishop f4 please
please just c6 open up the the exit door
yeah I like it
c6 both stops Knight b5 provides safety
and we're back to Robert's throat of
Bishop f4 and I think boy rook h5 is so
nice the bishop has to move and the rook
is now protected by the pawn instead of
the rook everyone the reason Bishop
before didn't work anymore is because
this rook on FA would have been
overwhelmed to guarding too much but
rook h5 with tempo means that no matter
where this Bishop moves we can get back
to Robert's idea of Bishop f4 and the
reason black wants us of course is
you're just you're better you want to
simplify the position so you know we're
striving for variations where black and
trade pieces off and then this rook has
a much better chance of out playing the
minors also what about Bishop d2 though
Bishop e2 like oh I can't play my bishop
before you have a skewer dirty girl but
you can maybe go rook fh8 to protect the
bishop on h2 it out that might be the
way to go
nobody's getting again but you know no I
like that because then I can go back to
King c7 bring the Bishop to d6 and I'm
still on the path to to coordinating my
fish about I'd say you're on the path to
righteousness fella I left that out a
long time ago buddy it's true okay it's
nice tea for drinks tea sets up a Keaney
six might be played well okay we thought
I would say is Bishop e7 an idea here
but Bishop e7 t a rook f7 and rook takes
h2 now I don't think you can't do seven
yeah yeah you can't trade down yeah no
he backs up but I think we're gonna get
your Bishop a4 idea or I think we should
yeah he goes for it and okay why does
some minimal compensation maybe for the
exchange in the sense that there's
drawing chances not winning chances for
white but maybe drawing chances because
whatever the pawns all go to ones
of the board it just makes it easier for
the miners to be able to compete with
the rook and protect each other the big
issue is that this King for white is so
far away from protecting the Queen side
that you still really like blacks
chances especially with this past H pawn
so and the clock and the clock right but
just if Roman X's and O's perspective
we've seen - now back to back I don't
want to say brilliance ease but great
games from the young polish rising chess
star he's uh he's making this a match
and given them I mean you got a look on
the bright side given that he only lost
another game because of a one move
blunder overall he played well you got
to be feeling confident right now if
you're due to that you know you haven't
you haven't played the worst chess yes
stop playing the Sicilian and get better
bait take got a cough skis advice and
you know you'll be alright
yep okay this is just over Tecton good
especially with no time for Grichuk the
problem for white is that the rook is
gonna land on f2 at some point yep and
then you know in okay root G a nice
route good enough the brook is just
gonna cut off the king and he's working
it with no diggity to the second-ranked
he's not backing it up he's moving
forward you know what he's he is
certainly shaking what his mama gave him
though yep I just five years out I out
unnecessary hip hop's on reference to
you right there you did you did and I
love them Brooksie four wins and take
everyone and the future is so bright
he's he actually forgot his shades
but have a question Danny yep how many
poems were enough to win that game as he
does it take to get to the center of a
tootsie roll pop six there you go so all
right well no but look at that we have a
match right there I was a little bit
there was a little bit of that moment
having you know we've seen these things
go off the rails so quickly when a
player starts losing you know the tilt
emotes come out and you just can't
recover in a format where you don't have
time to think about the loss emotionally
let it go but due to that's not the case
he blundered a queen and one move for
those of you just joining us in a game
that for all you know practical purposes
he never should have lost and but he's
recovered
won the next two games and the bleeding
has stopped Duda is making a batch out
of this
yeah I'm not curious about that you know
cuz sasha is a fan favorite he's
definitely a favorite amongst highly
rated players we just love Sasha right
who does though I'm wondering you know
where the fans are rooting for because
Duda is young he's inspiring
he beat cardiac in so yeah William full
of both chats I'm glad you I want to
feel like the chest TV chat has been a
little more due to ish if I if I'm white
a lot of diamond members that seem to be
rooting for the young underdog but but I
do agree I think Sasha for the most part
is the is one of the most popular I said
giri was the best interview and chess
and then got one of the funniest moments
you know I've ever had and but but I
think that Grichuk is also a very good
interview anybody who's been following
you know the sing filled cup or you know
events of over in any format over the
last few months you know that Grisha can
can really be a fun person to talk to
oh yeah you can just go to youtube and
look up Kirk thug life or whatever that
is but in this game I'm not sure he's
gonna feel like the best because again
it's just one of those positions where
White has slightly more space yeah this
time on both sides of the board because
the poem before is it's just nice to
have you know pong goes further advanced
the night can come to f5 for white where
h6 of course isn't under threat you guys
met preemptively because he realizes
night of five will be annoying and the
problem with playing with like 97 it
makes it harder to play d5 as your ePHI
pond was defense and nights for it I
mean he played it it's sort of obvious
for the night eh for Queen f3 throw
named Bishop takes h6 you 39 to f5 so
yeah
okay night it just won't play tonight at
5:00 there it is
yeah as someone who's played the black
side of this too many times I'm never
comfortable I just hate the space the
fact that I have to you know sort of
watch out for night takes 86 or might
take the Chi seven all the time I just I
hate it
frankly it just feels so terrible so
let's see King enjoyment
there he goes KH 1 blackened by d5 yeah
that's really the way the black has to
you talk about why you hated is black
and rightfully so especially if the
structure remains and the game is all
about what White's doing to you over on
the H and G spot I mean if you but if
you can change the nature of the game
punch defy through open the center
that's how black gets that's why black
plays these positions is that they feel
that this is solid enough you can defend
eventually you do get to change things
and we've already seen Grichuk be
successful on the black side of the
structure one time in this match so far
ok I mean 97 you can always replace that
night with another 9 f5 and then playing
g4 and then play g5 and that's where g5
seems like what he's gonna do now to me
black is playing for clear counter play
with d5 and you can't stop it because c4
black would just play c6
so Queen g3 a nice night for f4 this
that's better than what I was suggesting
that's for sure by playing f4 you open
up this rook and you hit the e5 square
so for example Knight mighty eight you
don't really want to make a move like
that a knight h5
similarly quite minute meant by Queen h4
1098 played and not f4 there's there's
no way for black to try to squeeze in a
g6 because the night takes h6 and then
f5 discovered check so so yeah f4 does
look like what the doctor ordered but
when some point Black has to strike back
with something like d5 and right and d5
now the pawn takes e5 pawn takes 4 d4
and you're just you know I closed down
the position and you
Blackstar would hold on chain and that
would be a nightmare switching over here
to the Batcave to show your instructor
point because I love I love when you
start dropping knowledge Bobby yes I had
my moments
said I'm trying to think here because
you think with the bishop enough for
then black might be able to get away
with d5 the point being that you can't
play e5 now with your night hanging on
f5 so between takes a 4d v e5 maybe
black goes d4 there and still is a bit
uncomfortable so here's the rook how is
he meeting d5 now he must have some sort
of tactic like on rookie for going after
c7 or maybe even rook h4 maybe oh maybe
D v e5 Queen e5 Knight takes h6 oh look
at that that rook takes f7 and the Queen
is falling everyone but I actually don't
even think it works honestly because my
back rank is so weak for a white that
I'm pretty nervous to do something like
that so d5 what else could he be
you know but I think I think the first
couple moves I suggested either rookie
for Brooke h4 both have concrete threats
yeah rook h4 looks awesome
yeah for sure so I think I think he
meets d5 with a with a rook lift and
actually this is becoming harder and
harder to suggest a move for Krishna and
could we really see the third win in a
row from the young the young polish star
and bring this match into at I headed
into the three report I mean were we're
really seeing seeing him hold himself
together Bishop d2 here has to be
consideration d4 for white why not d4
for white big center use it I'm not I'm
not I mean you could even just develop
the Bishop to d2 or something and try to
get the other rook over to f1 but I I
agree I like big centers and I cannot
live so d4 is also on my mind
Ana's a Queen f3 comes to mind hitting
age 5 Queen I find it if you're talking
about hitting age 5
Queen g5 as well oh yeah Queen g5 I kind
of wanted to hmm maybe Queens you for
actually Queen g5 looks suddenly a TV ad
has become full of full of some of the
strongest players on the web we've got
Hikaru Nakamura over at chess TV saying
he agrees age five looks suspect we got
in the house are in who needs to update
his title on chest contra GM Newhouse
are and one of the youngest GM's on the
planet we got him in the chest TV chat
he just became it to him so shout out to
everybody watching this whether you're
on twitch or chest comm TV Bishop III I
liked it I liked Bishop d2 to get
developed but this also makes sense why
it's just gonna bring more pieces over
here to the Kings side yeah and also the
mission when he three closes off a third
rank from attacking the Queen and what I
mean by that is now after pawn takes c4
rook takes you for there's no rook takes
d3 hitting the Queen on g3 uh-huh so he
kind of back to the same situation where
I'm not sure you were wrong the clea for
Queen g5 weren't the more aggressive
ways to go after this suspect h5 move as
a carro said but rookie what's wrong
this looks very good for white rook e1
I'm threatening you know to take on d5
or play e5 if you take on e4 I can even
I just take with the e-book or I play d4
first but hmm so what about back to your
ePHI idea if Queen takes it not even
something with the knife but just flip
the rook to the e-file looks really good
because you're threatening rook takes
the eight removing the guard of the g7
square yeah you got tactics on g7 and if
Queen f6 is forced I guess I kind of
assumed there'd be a discovery on the
Queen with the night but I don't see
maybe I don't know what it is but maybe
moving the night from f5 even to like h4
d4 or something yeah I throwing in Queen
f3 there and he did it only 5:45 yeah
here we go okay so what's the discovery
so I think Queen f3 might be a useful
inclusion and the point is that of
course I'm attacking the h5 pawn
there it is yeah your G sticks I have
Knight h6 winning f7 so very nice
this has been what this has been quite
impressive and quite the turnaround
right now hey Garo drop in the honey
badger language said that it was nasty
e-5 nasty
and here comes any here comes 97 and 98
six I'd like your move - I'm just saying
I like your move just as much as I like
a carros move Robert thank you
appreciate it
although I yeah my cars remove is better
though your mom may like it car is much
better but I like your move just as much
thank you appreciate that yeah 97 is a
deadly threat meet King g8 and 97 to
check making matters worse there's no
way to protect this h5 pawn I guess you
know queen g6 but still met by 97 and
the you know for everyone watching the
important point 97 it's cutting off the
rooks protection the f7 square so yeah
this is over yeah I shouldn't say Oprah
we got criticized about this in the past
I will take that back but it looks very
very very very very bad for black and I
also will say that Judah was down two
games and he came back against Carr
yakin and use down two games in this
match he's about to even it up against
Chris Rock so he needs it a little bit
of you know warm up to start wreaking
havoc on his opponents oh wait Queen H 5
H 5 looks okay rook hates war yeah
Jesus Queen h7 King f8 Queen Anne she
made you take on a chamber that's a
force problem on the h-file damn dooda
dooda he can hardly hold back a smile I
love it I love the young he's just so
excited right did you see do you see him
trying to hold back that smile hopefully
yeah he clipped that I guess that was it
was adorable that was cute yeah like
nicest guy he won his third game in a
row so he should be happy you know
against against a former world blessed
champion but somebody woke him up after
blundering that Queen Duda has has
arrived right yeah you know do you think
his polish teammates are somewhere in
the background
say hey wake up yeah exactly bringing
him a snack or something he looks like
he's in the gym this is his home
although we haven't asked him in our in
our pre pregame what we're all kind of
hanging out I assume this is this is the
same place he was in when he played
Sergei Corey Aachen so I assume this is
his home yeah unless they're even doing
some training camp or something he's
still in the same spot yeah I'd assume
it's just so but and I assume wearing
Chris Chuck's chin again correction
hottie pointing out that we have an
amazing view of Bishops chin that's what
you came to see was Sasha's chin you you
are welcome
so all right well we have another Petrov
it worked out despite the queen blunder
the opening itself worked out the last
time that the Polish fighter played this
and this isn't gonna be the same type of
Petrov but it is a Russian defense here
white where do we see this recently we
saw a Carlson Caruana at the sink field
cub not exactly this move order but the
same type of structure on the queenside
butt and those in deposition Carlson had
a much better King side attack and here
it looks like we're just getting a bunch
of minor pieces traded yeah I mean what
white tries to do is use that spacial
advantage and it's no small part caused
by the fact you give these double pawns
or you open the file for you look you
may say you say that my pond c4 is more
advanced upon d6 it takes away your
access to d5 square by the same time
block is super solid and in this
particular position even the bishop
takes f6 does happen and something end
of the world for black because it's
really hard to you tiny crusher so for
example Castle queenside Bishop f6 Queen
f6 take two G takes f6 your pawn
structures ugly but you know looks can
be deceiving
yep especially with when it's not on an
open file these double isolated pawns
are just not nearly as weak as you would
think they also have some benefits they
control central squares the G file
becomes open so it's an instructive
point that not to just dismiss
dogmatically that the doubled pawns will
be terrible for black and speaking of
not dismiss daddy moon says well it's
taken five years but Danny wrench has
grown on me
rakesh in the chesty be chat it makes it
makes a point that if this game ends
decisively will this be the first time
we've never had a draw in the five
minute portion unfortunately that's a
real assignment for our stat guy behind
the scenes
um that would be amazing right first
time we've never had a peaceful result
all decisive games in the five-minute
portion if this one ends that way of
course I probably changed it exactly I
which means they're gonna agree to a
draw if you would draw by just J and
that is jinx it so interesting though
they are spending quite a bit of time
here clearly both not super familiar
with the current setup I mean it is kind
of odd but due to solid here you don't
really want to take on f3 because Knight
f3 Bishop f6 Queen f6 Queen takes pawn
takes Bishop f3 you do improve White's
Bishop so that's their be the bad thing
about taking on f3 and you can just
cancel Queen side as black as well
there's no real rush to take on that 3
because white doesn't particularly want
to take on e5 so I can't with ambition
g5 things so this is the final game of
the 5 minute section that's clear and I
think blacks doing ok here yeah time is
run out so no matter what it is the last
game the players have been notified
what's the problem with taking on g5 as
well because in megi 6 clearly makes
sense but if you take on g5 it's not
that big a deal after white plays Knight
takes d5 in response so yeah I mean you
could counsel long I was I was wondering
if there's something on c4 but not not
as long as your kinks in the center I
agree night-night the night on g5 was
not a big deal but 96 also looks ok for
black the Queen will back up and it's
just a matter of time I think before
black castles probably long although
here you can even Castle short I mean if
Duda wants to play for a win it's a
tight match you know yeah age 6 them
good move say okay you go retrieve
Bishop e3 but now I'm going for the f4
square so why can't play Knight d4 and
that's something
that of course you should consider here
and by playing 94 you attack this bishop
on e6 not that black has too big of an
issue with you capturing it but it will
change the dynamic of the game the f2
pawn is something that whitens keep an
eye on now
yeah Foursquare is blacks for the taking
so indeed and and dudas really showing
his eye not to say he believes he's just
gonna check maker it but I mean your
your castling short knowing that you're
putting the Kings on opposite sides of
the board which means it could become
one of those race positions g3 prepares
ideas like f4 and h4 and and both sides
might be trying to attack the other King
so I just I like the confidence from the
young men right I like it I agree and
what I also like is this stat from
smarter chess that after doing some
digging Caruana ofon didn't have a draw
in the 5 minute portion ah ok well there
you go
once again smarter chess fighting for my
clients job so letting Mike know that
he's not the only one coming up with
stats behind the scene just kidding we
love you both and shout out to the
entire team that helps make these events
possible and our mods both on the chest
comm TV chat and here on Twitch chess
Bay Gotham chess Gotham just not a mod
no he isn't mine oh yeah just pay Gotham
chess Bigfoot much love
hey Carlos saying the Queen takes of two
is possible yeah that's what I was
thinking right we never who sees a pawn
he takes a pawn so we might want to
listen to him no I was it's the first
thing that came to mind because I don't
say you're trapping my Queen if I take
enough to e play room D de f1 I'd like
Queen to g2 and my queen what goes out
of there yeah will you you have a lot of
ways to wiggle out actually there's I
don't think what White is even close to
trapping the Queen yeah and he's taking
his time due to zoom zoned in and
Grichuk
thinking a little bit looks like their
cameras were frozen but okay they're
back now but dooda dooda was focused in
decided he could take it and we're gonna
we're gonna find out if krishna can
prove him wrong
well the Queen just come back into the
game so you know Queen comes to e34
can't even go through Age 3 if you take
on e6 pawn 66 you open up the a file for
the black rook and after h4 well you're
still not thrown into when the Queen
then I can always come to e5 and that's
the important thing I removed in the F
pawn is well you won upon but of course
the e5 square is now completely blacks
Knights for the taking
yep and he and he feels it he likes it
he agrees with you so I don't know what
to do in response okay now the c4 pawn
is actually under attack so rook hg one
of you a queen e for rook at four you
can even retreat your queen back to g6
or h7 but after rook hg one you may even
be able to play queen h2 or three yeah I
mean if you're willing to to take a
peaceful result - you can totally sit
tight but I don't think black should
take a piece towards I think black is
the one who is preferred because the
pawn you took the F pawn yeah something
you stole the Jeep on and now your
King's under threat you took an F on
things totally fine and it was a it's
the healthiest pollen right I mean it's
the the chance to get her to get a win
in the endgame
hey Carlo being critical of grishnack
and the chess TV chat but I'll say from
a practical point of view at the very
least this is a game that's gonna come
down to a time scramble and given that
grishnack has a minute and 40 seconds to
do this 23 I don't think we should we
should say that grishnak is is out of
this game yet not at all yep by the way
we have world junior champion
Aram Moxon Zulu I probably miss Francis
last name he was in the track good good
effort yeah grandmaster poem of his
username shoutout graduations a nine and
a half out of ten performance before
before the last don't even began nice to
see a world junior champion hanging out
what
to the show today yeah pretty awesome
stuff and here if you're black
okay so nice yeah 95 I've been well it
could bring the Knight to c3 if you're
griffa alright okay throw any maiden one
don't one or Queen anyone checking right
and okay 25 was one of those moves that
you sort of gain a tempo and stop Bishop
athletes out despite the fact that black
is better here and I know objectively a
car was right on it the clock and the
fact that grishnack is gonna orchestrate
g5 I just feel like from a practical
perspective this is blitz don't play 95
you wanna play 95 Bishop h7 shy Bishop
h7 would be the second blunder of the
Queen and a Petra off by Judah but he
doesn't do it and don't play rook up for
cuz Queens you won the rooks hanging so
g5 from Brooke ooh
95 he's trying to draw the Queen into an
undefended squared look at that if
Bishop takes pawn takes either the
knight moves everyone lose the Queen or
the Queen takes and looses the Queen so
95 a sneaky move by Sasha
Gordon responds in my opinion by do as
Queen c5 one second though b6 take on a
Texas man oh you should have taken on h6
if you were Grichuk taking h6 you win on
time but look how quickly this is turned
around and watch out Knight f3 is the
threat for black I mean there's three
wonder where it is there it is night of
three no blacks better now watch out for
that rook on g1 or are you getting mated
what if I took you six I thought there
might have been a oh six oh we missed it
oh and he backs up knowing that I missed
it worse
Wow Wow where did back up quickly before
we take our break everyone don't go
anywhere we'll have about a 60 second
break here yeah yeah Sasha go ahead take
a break we we have to back up to this
position here where it seemed that after
Bishop Queen d4 Bishop d3 black was
still in the driver's seat but perhaps
rook rook cd8 was the mistake
well 95 was a great shot by gross joke
especially in due time trouble 95 and I
think you were right I think if he had
even played
age six here he might have gotten him to
flag immediately whether it's
objectively best or not but I think
instead of rook si de eight Robert black
can either just move the Queen to c5
immediately get rid of this opportunity
for ninety five or even consider whether
g4 is a pawn you could capture with
Bishop takes c4 and then h5 cementing
the Queen yes the G foil mr. pink g4 was
definitely something that is scary to
play but there may not be a useful way
to dislodge that Bishop from g4 and if
Black gets a move right that G file
closes down pretty much for good so all
right well if you're just joining us
about 4,000 of you with us now
don't go anywhere this match is only
just heating up after a 4-1 advantage
for Sasha Grishka Duda came storming
back won three in a row and you saw what
just happened there Grichuk returns the
favor stops the bleeding
wins the final game to head this into
the the three-minute portion we had zero
draws we had 0 draws in the five-minute
portion Robert hopefully that's a sign
of exciting chess to come you and I will
be right back and we will see everyone
in about 60 90 second season well as we
said it's been exciting it's been a back
and forth match exactly what the the
people pay to see and if we take a look
at exactly what the stats told us and
the media pre game versus what versus
what we're seeing now we're seeing some
fun in terms of the back and forth of
those emotes
everyone loves heads on a stick I think
or is that like meets on a stick like
hot dogs or corn dogs I don't know no
sure no come not really big hot all
right well we are a big fan of is the
way these two guys have played chess
thank you to everyone who's here 4000 of
you with us now remember that for
subscribers today we have a raffle going
on we got a merch giveaway that's going
to go down at the end of this portion
here and of course we we know that
everything in the merch store as well as
all donations and bits today go directly
to the players and their price once so
looks like we are about to get underway
here in the three minute portion I'm
ready if you're ready
and nearly the players are ready because
here we go
yep and we have d4 this time from here
we saw this yep earlier we saw him take
on f6 and that way he got a very nice
game it's like the best game we've seen
so far of really for him I think as
white yeah yep and that was this very
nice game in here and said he doesn't
take on f6 and it doesn't get this
position where it takes an upstate ok is
Krisha played Bishop g7 up the regiment
you fought and if you take on d4 with
the e pawn you enter a caro-kann
structure we're in an exchange Carrick
on on the d5 square it that way you
change the the symmetry there's no it's
an asymmetric pollen structure if he
takes d5 yeah instead he more of like a
exchange Slav structure where you play
CD 5 CD 5 and now you say ok I'm going
to be first the open C file yep or
hopefully you'll be first right and also
importantly the bishop on h4 can retreat
to g3 in a moment and say I'm at a
better diagonal as bishop on g7 from the
bishop on g7 to open up you'll have to
move this night away and play e5 but
that could create weaknesses in Blacks
camp so we sell a pause there on the
clock
after Grisha took on d4 do you think
that do you think that Duda was
considering strongly to which structure
he really wanted here taking with the
year the c1 maybe even trying to recall
some preparation oh absolutely I think
well I'm not positive the preparation
aspect but I think he was it's a very
critical decision on what structure you
want to get into and so ii takes d4
would have been that care of khan
exchange structure and instead he opts
for this which is I think quite easy for
black to play honestly you can play
Bishop f5 here followed up with 94 can
play you know g5 if he wants to be a
little bit more aggressive I wouldn't
probably not start with that if I were
black but Bishop f5 is sort of a an easy
move to play follow the rook c8 just go
he plays a 3 and I was hoping for each
takes d4 I may because I wanted to talk
about a minority attack pawn structure
for black and and the type of efile and
maybe King side attack for white but
instead we're in a boring I mean you
know a semi Slav actually
love so yeah I mean I don't know and why
the players you know it's makes so much
time and I really think that this is if
not known position it's very similar to
known position so they have time they
can use in there actually even on the
clock right now but tricky position
because black play f5 here and by
playing f5 you do in fact threaten at
some moment a g5 that port doesn't trap
the bishop quite yet but it does give
you huge progress in the d4 pawn is
undermined so you can of the d4 point
one of the other ideas in the structure
is not just g5 and a4 but to move the
Queen off of the pin right and then
strike with e5 also trying to undermine
d4 and open up the bishop on the the
long diagonal here right absolutely and
if you're white you're already in a
little bit of a tough spot because you
can play bishop g3 intend to meet he
five with him probably d5 but still your
Bishop on g3 is not gonna be happy when
that pawn at five eventually makes its
way to f4 yep and white of course would
love black to take on d5 but then the
bishop would come to c4 in this
variation Robert was giving on the
analysis board but I'm liking the
direction of position for Grichuk and of
course the way that the time is being
managed also tells us that perhaps dude
is a little a little uncomfortable here
not not sure how he's going to deal with
natural plan the Queen moves off the
diagonal black one c5 as Robert said
you'd love to play this but that
probably doesn't really stop e5 okay he
castles short but now we're back to your
idea of either g5 immediately and maybe
e5 to follow or just move the Queen and
try to get a five before you overextend
the cheap on but I'm not sure what's
better g5 or just move the Queen okay
Grichuk is all in here we go right yeah
looks
pretty good for blacks you can play f4
here for Cee takes f4 and then you can
take on f4 back and then after Bishop h4
the d4 pawn is hanging but so is the e4
pawn and black King might be a little
bit iffy bad so I mean f4 ef4 GF for oh
he's gonna go for it yeah he must take
with the Queen okay yeah that would kill
two birds with one stone
take d4 and defend e4 it seems you know
it's almost too straightforward to be
true like the three minute has has put
young Christoph back to sleep after he
found himself right now he just down
more than a minute on the clock and lost
to go with it yeah now b2 can be
captured in the near future I wouldn't
capture him be to quite yet I don't
think with the e4 pawn hanging but
either tactic being Queen takes b2
Knight takes e4 Queen takes a one looks
like you just win the exchange but big
Queen b3 check Oh Queen yeah couldn't
either check comes in and I take your
rook and you know to understand the
dynamic between two rooks versus a queen
with King safety is involved or knowing
that King is because always better have
the Queen to launch an attack so Bishop
f5 is the calm move makes a lot of sense
and okay East 7th pawn good for you rook
f7 here follow that up with I mean
either III or bring the other rook in
okay maybe now you want to be dating -
yeah I was gonna say you got to be a
little cautious about Bishop c3 so he
plays rook to d8 not sure I love that
what's this I what's he meeting Bishop
c3 with yeah I'm not positive
backs up if he oh that's a weird move a
weird but necessary move because if you
took on g7 there you know just take back
on g7 the 92 is in a bit of trouble so
you take with rook on g7 threatening
wish you h3 so instead allows the
exchange to happen on the c3 score
ignored by black but now the d4 square
as whites from the taking and this is
the blockade setup yeah this is this is
a
much improved structure from what do to
had earlier I don't like the way that
Grichuk handled that middle game
especially given the time in vain and
she had it now now he has hardly any
time advantage yep now the before the D
496 happens to 1:1 we got a two-on-one
on the queenside that's a Paul majority
yeah look at this take over that d4
square love it okay what were see what
flex fine you know a sign black should
be in danger that the clocks choice is
gonna tell the tailor Wow so roopd fort
is is gonna come at some point alright
this is I mean spring the King the
center how can you complain look h7
didn't mean to go room g7 I wonder I
wonder if it was a mouse slip because
now now it's a critical temple lost
White's getting active the knight on c5
is super strong best piece on the board
yes this is completely slipped away from
Grichuk yeah I think dude has done well
here and the outside passed pawn is very
important you know King can always be
safe on the d4 square trading I'm one
pair of rooks is smart the granted wife
does have this H pawn which could be
difficult to do in some no but there's a
the dominance and coordination of the of
the rook Knight and King on the dark
squares make that bishop on e6 feel left
out Oh was there okay for there did he
just missed okay for know I guess King
III would have been okay but but I'm not
sure I'd really saw that Nix it's not
enough though rook here it comes to see
one with check it's gonna end in a draw
D D for I keep checking forever okay
watch out for Brooke b5 did he just miss
Rooke b5 no rugby five take take d3
oh it's queen with Chad no it's quit it
was Queen we check the King was on f4
yeah but this is still no it's not so
enough I guess it makes me enough well
you cannot you can keep checking and if
I Brooke f1 both players completely
locked in right now due to blinking his
eyes to wake up wait what is in white I
think White's just winning black has to
give up take the rook take the rough to
bring in you Queen it doesn't matter
a minute rook is a notice happening
there I don't know I don't know what
just happened but Duda is gonna end up
on the winning side of it that's all
that matters if you're if you're in the
Polish camp
Grichuk takes a deep breath shakes his
head cuz we're right there with you oh
we don't know how that game happened
I mean I know that Black was much better
throughout most the middle game yet a
Miss played a Miss played approach and
suddenly due to had everything he needed
the night was better than the bishop he
had a tomb own majority and there you go
yep
no that was ridiculous because you know
work out for one was always an
opportunity when the king was in c6 the
take on f6 with check and then get rid
of the other pawn as well so clear
missed opportunity from Bishop earlier
of course Chris Chuck was better I think
rook h7 was a mouse slip yeah then he
had to go back to g7 and everything was
you know neutralized by then and here we
see that we're talking on the earlier
game if you take these bishop on e6 this
time was taken with a bishop
okay F takes c6 now at the end of the
world and black will will be solid but
white does have more space the open D
file or semi open D file I should say
you know can be used for white at some
point playing c5 but if you play c5
black goes d5 and is not complaining so
no but uh like you said it's it's been a
resourceful day for for Duda and even
hey Carter Nakamura saying in the chest
EB shot that he agrees agrees that
Grichuk may need a lead in the bullet
portion if he's gonna win this match we
saw what happened in the match between
Duda and Sergei Kuryakin where what call
it surprising or not young Christophe
completely dominated the fastest portion
and so if that pattern continues then
Grichuk is really gonna look back at
some of these games as big missed
opportunities for sure and right now you
know rook is using an active approach
but it's not active in the sense where
he's going all-out for the win he's just
trying to make progress here on the
Queen side of course b5 is the threat if
you play b6 is black I think that might
be the best way to handle this but a
sixth and b5 still comes but beefs
is the opposite because then it'd be
five you actually are super happy with
the 1985 hitting c4 so right and b6
makes sense
b6 maybe white can consider c5 as well
just having a new target to work with
because let's say B 65 now if you go d5
perhaps they go b5 myself and you say
you still have to be careful in those
lines because the C 4 square is so
dangerous especially with the bishop on
f6 but but no it's a good point to
highlight that there's a lot of
trickiness happening with the pawn so
and he's gonna go for your line c5 I
like just playing d5 if I'm black but
what if i speaking of my powerful bishop
on f6 what if i take on c5 and call your
bluff with the b-pawn let's tuck my King
on a8 and here comes the rook to the B
foil yeah definitely possibie c5 BC by
King 8 I might have to try a rook d3 to
b3 but yeah you're right that looks that
looks sketchy to say the least maybe be
c5 drive b5 is white now probably now
that was an ID for EMS BC 5v5 via 94
everything's protected or it would seem
so Duda taking his time to consider the
critical moment decides he doesn't like
the B file idea well but Grichuk is I
mean this is a worrisome game at this
one backfires and he loses cuz after
losing the last game it almost feels
like a tilt ish attack for white here
opening up your own King just to try to
get these pawns to move forward and this
was definitely better by the way after B
takes e5 just was having a clear brain
fart Bishop takes e5 would have been
strong oh why just making take advantage
of the pin on the default but now this
King is on c1 and if that Queen can get
to the c3 square its lights out but okay
Queenie for it going 100% is right into
the attack if Queen takes c6 then
there's Queen takes c4 with check and
the King on c1 is not going to survive
that much longer so it can play pawn
takes d5 that's an option you can play
Queen back to slowest they can't and I
play Knight d2
attacking the Queen and guarding c4 but
I guess you just have Queen e5
threatening they don't be - yeah that
looks quite frustrating okay he goes for
it but here comes Queen e5 I'm guessing
yeah honey or queen d3 threatening the
same idea wiggle the Queen in in the
old-fashioned way here Queen c3 check
again this like we not trying to repeat
ideas we've said earlier but it just has
felt from the moment that Grichuk played
b4 followed it of really aggressively
with c4 and c5 that bit of a tilt ish
attack just the kind of attack that
doesn't have a lot what I mean by that
it doesn't have a lot of positional
grounding it's not like blacks King was
inherently open or particularly weak and
all you did was really create targets
for black along these these diagonals so
hence the term kind of a kind of a tilt
ish attack so we'll see maybe maybe
there's some way for for grishnak to get
out of this but this looks really really
tough Robert what do you play here is
white again you can't take c6 as you
said we take c6 is matin - Queen c3 and
Queen B - yeah no I'm worried about I'm
trying to figure it out what I can do
here to even prolong the game you play
Queen b3 but at the very least you're
losing the b4 pawn right Queen takes b3
let's say take with the pond b3 the
knight takes before right and you're
upon and the simpler code yeah an
important important law to house the
simple life my client points out that
we've had 12 games and only 2 were both
sides Castle kingside
or sorry we've had 11 games yeah they
don't like to castle they don't like to
Castle kingside apparently apparently
they're they're into the long castle ok
pawn takes b6 makes sense now Queen c3
Czech Queen c2 blocks and that way Queen
a1 check you can just block again yeah
but you obviously do to here I was
wonder if you could even take with the C
pawn ok he plays the I wanted Queen c3
Czech Queen c2 night before Queen takes
c3 Knight takes a - check oh I love it
when you talk to act
that's winning upon with tempo followed
by maybe even d4 in a lot of positions
because that Bishop is gonna be trapped
and dooda dooda likes it
Duda likes a lady he gets the Queen back
on c3 that's only the seventh time I've
used that reference today Knight takes
b5 is none so yeah too many points it's
over do do what you just gonna wind up
on time up two pawns completely lost for
white and here comes rook to c5
they c6 the real custom move don't lose
on time barely doesn't mean five b5 okay
before okay seventh and Creek resigns
the Polish fighter proving his name true
now Sasha trying to rub the tired out of
his face
Sasha trying to rub the tired out of his
face although it should be noted this
match started an hour later than we've
normally had and it was actually
specifically by Alexander's request got
kids so I got a respect that he wanted
to make sure he played he played past
their bedtime so um a late match for
both these gentlemen playing from Moskva
and Poland but but they're both up to
the task
so and first leave for do down this
match
take out six five lead dude yeah and I
feel like it has a soccer star we'd get
a lot more chance going so I'm the one
I'm the one who has to do it in the
twitch chat got my other tater here just
so I can spam some do two heads
I like liquidator one-on-ones common the
chest comp slash TV chat Sasha is angry
night work Sasha angry night orphe yep
yep and dude okay he's opting or pretty
solid setup here
yep and that comes f1 can go into e3
just making sure that black is not
playing d5 and if you're white yes of
course you can play pawn a five and
there it is but sometimes you don't
wanna play that too soon because it does
allow black an opportunity to go after
that
in some positions and also you know the
good news for what of course is you
clamp down at night a for trying to go
to the b6 square well then if I was
hanging on the spot so that's why Bishop
b2 was useful look at this night go from
d7 to h7 you know if I saw my student do
that usually be in the you know not a
good situation but here it made sense
because night going to g5 couldn't
really pester White's King said in to
Queen d7 inviting night to b6 so close
Bishop d8 to stop that okay here it's
interesting moment because why is
several options of course you can play
Knight b6 but getting the bishop pair is
not as meaningful here in the d6 pawn
not yet under attack you know couldn't
be for and that way just sort of apply
more pressure on the d6 square and
preventing d5 as I was about to say but
let's see pawn d5 95 95 Bishop d5 Bishop
takes h6 that looks like a winner of a
pawn
so that's should be what's gonna happen
here it's gonna happen Bishop takes 95
Bishop takes a 6 it's not so simple at
the end of the line maybe black has
Knight f6 and if you trade on d5 and the
NC 2 Falls mmm okay you're talking here
so Bishop g5 it looks like White's still
better though wait ambition G yeah
Bishop g5 here looks good I'm just
trying to remove the guard wave of
Bishop g5 Bishop g2 Queen d7 9750 two
queens trade and the end black and win
the c2 pollen after black recaptures the
bishop on g2
hmm so the seats upon hanging is
important but how important Bishop g2
for Queen d7 97 take on g2 I guess as a
trait Queens that's the first thing or
is it gonna play King takes g2 and
invite the Queen trade on d1 Knight is
this way so Bishop takes a5 rook
II D 1 then Knight b6 well II rook
rookie d1 now there it is Gina tempo
tempo in the night but it still feels
like black should be getting out of this
just fine I'm not sure whether you take
two five or move the knight to the
square like f8 it can white really
defend both the a5 pawn and the c2 pond
no but if you're going to take on g5 I'm
happy to take on d7 and try to threaten
b7 if you go tonight a fade I was in go
Bishop e3 and if rook takes T - I wasn't
gonna night c5 I come after your b7 pawn
again so I wasn't sure if black
sometimes maybe pawn g5 rook d7 pawn h4
and this way does looks looks that or
takes you to first I meant yeah yeah it
takes teacher because upon each horse c4
half yeah I'm here and now a 5 and h4
are still falling
you know be for both to protect a 5 and
to allow 95 to happen next
you play Brooke takes B 7 I am concerned
about either gh4 first or Bishop a5
suppose H 5 look at that move saying
your pawn structure is bad if whites
Knight was on e4 you would say this is
strategically one for white if look f8
here
this is black wisely rook F 1 I guess
that looks yeah Brooke f8 rook F 1 and
then they're still gonna be tactics with
III though feels like black is getting
more counter plate and we thought that
he should with this transition so I
wonder if in hindsight this whole Bishop
takes h6 idea was was not the
simplification that white really wanted
only 26 seconds yeah Caracara saying
also feels like feels like do to mess
this up a little bit somewhere this I
definitely agree with that look good
okay he 141 contempo he was trying to
sacrifice in exchange and now he's just
losing a knight
ooh oh we rook d5 okay okay six would be
less than ideal as they say so do two
one from a good position to a losing one
and go shook with this will even up the
match Bishop c5 and can't rook f8 here
not totally necessary but yeah there's a
small pin problem
maybe g4 for black also is a guards the
bishop so that you can move the rook off
C - that's the idea
it's brutal okay - here
take on up to the bishop it honestly
doesn't matter that much but this is
this point is you can read flavors III
yeah Betty be eagle well it's just a
little old lady who you to rook c8 is
trying to made him in fact that does
made them I know the G for track is very
necessary at some point well II - now
wins because rook c8 Bishop things g3
was check and this is okay wait rook HH
egg rook c6 check no okay I'll go Brooke
c6 check now wait a second tigress chick
just totally blow this how does this
happen
no he missed six a six a six the bishop
can't move in time oh he missed it he
plays rook to c2 no oh did he know
really just have a win with a six he
could have went to a six and the point
was that you have to go Bishop f2 to
stop the a pawn and then I got ya yeah
he missed it
okay wait a second he's nice I'm
building up or she was here with the
Jeep on it's trying to back up to the
position that she had where you talked
about a six I love seeing a car in the
the chess accompt Evie chat you can tell
when he's really not happy with some of
the moves trying to back up but it's
hard to get there yeah it's all good
yeah just crazy crazy finish and that
that probably should've been a you know
that they're definitely fortress
opportunities there but I think that was
a winning position
I was crazy amazing and yes I was
struggling with limited time in the
clock we've seen that for sure well he
manages to get the win there barely but
only because of blunders and swindles
but hey Cara now making a bold
prediction that he thinks do too will
actually win as long as he's as long as
he's not down by more than one point in
the bullet so would be another amazing
amazing upset but at this point I think
no point in looking ahead because we
have enough exciting chests right in
front of us and we have another Petroff
we're due to now is literally playing
the line that he had where he hung his
Queen right we've got the structure of
an isolated deep pond this is very
similar to I believe it was game for
Game four in Game five black will
probably play 96 I think you're are you
willing to invite the double pawns or
maybe you want to play c6 here okay he
doesn't want the double pawns apparently
yeah well night before is the tempo
right hit the bush 25 and threaten 92 or
93 so and what's wrong with know what is
it a thing about with 94 my missing
something
okay plays it after 13 second okay 13
seconds not a tremendous amount of time
but felt very straightforward
all right so two bishops advantaged for
black and the good news for white is
with this night no longer on f6 d5 can
become an easier possibility the bad
news for white that even if you played
d5 white black will go c5 and has been
perfect night blockade on the d6 square
yeah so not the position you really want
to see is why you don't want to just
love that blockade to be strong what we
should we'll play Knight to e5 and by
putting his knight on e5 he's just
getting more space pressurize in the f7
square making blacks life as difficult
as possible and trying to think here how
to really want to kick this bishop off
the B 3 square but I don't see any way
to do so you know playing B 585 things
like that but I can just ignore just
putting a Bishop to c4 that's gonna be
his way of doing so but rook beat hmm no
rookie - doesn't work as I intended it
to
I wanted to play rook d2 with the idea
of Bishop c4 and to play d5 or they does
not before she does not pan out so rook
III played and she's ignoring the bishop
and playing Bishop C - don't play 95 now
because Bishop to g5 will be the
response and there's a problem with the
h4 is a thematic vintage style chest
nice elated queen pawn kind of move to
make you gonna play h5 hopefully put
your knight on e5 swing that rook knows
you swing that rook and deliver the
goods somewhere on h7 or f7
I wish chess were just that easy right
well sometimes it can be that easy if
you're watching your shows now I
survived I thought you were going
somewhere else with that but
everybody g5 here is black and then
Truckee five would be quite double-edged
though right you don't want to give the
permanent control over the light square
diagonal there it gets Delaney's off the
board makes sense so in synchrony I was
gonna say are there tactics on e6 I
think so yeah no G six place should be
four rub g3 takes d4 rook g3 and open
him yeah that's the attack is actually
just as dangerous as it would be with
the Queen's on the board so that's seems
like a tactic that was missed when do to
played Queen f6 although his forehead
isn't very revealing of his emotions but
I think we can guess that he didn't see
this this tactic or appreciated so you
can take g6 right away but that's the
way black wants you to capture because
if your bishop takes d4 rook takes g6
check is very annoying but if the
bishops already on g6 then Bishop takes
d4 at the very least makes blacks test a
little bit simpler it was d5 so Bishop
c3 is upon c3 and then I'll take on g6
check and say that I'm a pawn I have a
bishop verse tonight things are looking
up
g5 White's just simplifying though it
doesn't look like there's gonna be
enough to deal with the fact that he's
just down to Poland oh I wouldn't be so
quick to dismiss blacks chances I mean
to figure out a plan for for white I
thought it okay it's slightly risky but
I like the idea of playing chief or if I
can just just okay he goes g3 I don't
know why not g4 to threaten g5 and open
up the door to g6 he'll go F for King G
to f4 okay a slow play it slow Jamz slow
Jamz 2018 yep
my new playlist I thought your players
included the New York sirens out your
window but no no that's just life oh
yeah g3
kimchi - I still think g4 was better but
the point is as you said white doesn't
prove in a win but black
to find moves while he's the one in a
worse position and down on time you
played a 95 I don't really want the
opposite code Bishop ending but I guess
I kind of have to allow it
Knight takes pawn takes black it's rook
T to know what's the trade unfortunately
two pawns now it feels like this was too
much
two pawns too much advance the C pawn I
like it he was trying to push pawn to a6
just to get that pawn as far as possible
Duda does well to stop that pawn
although actually you're gonna play a
five and try to take the Jeep on nobody
gets the Brooks off the board you gotta
have better Joe why so Bishop is in the
right color important to note the
Bishnoi need for matches the AIDS we're
right that's key but still it felt like
you have better chances of poking and
prodding at weaknesses the more pieces
you keep on the board blacks under time
pressure yeah this is actually the pawn
means are too close to each other yeah I
was gonna say if you have if you're one
file further G and C you have a blockade
but the problem with pushing the f1 is
that blacks Bishop is on an ideal
diagonal to both guard the queening
square everyone let's say of the F pawn
and squares like c5 so it's okay I'm
being slightly abstract and kind of
describing potential blockades you know
maybe maybe Leela or stockfish or
something proves us wrong but okay now
he keeps the G pause okay that was key
that might change the evaluation because
now the bishop cannot sit on a block
painting square and a queening square
which is an instructive point for those
wondering how to how to play these
endings that that might win the endgame
for for Sasha right there Robert yeah
but it's still gonna be hard to make
progress here the pawns are very far
apart which is nice but I think okay
yeah you're right okay he's managed to
reach a square that guards both but now
he's okay that wasn't big yeah he's he's
lost now can't guard both
Bishop will come to me five and then the
King will eventually wiggle its way in
although will it be nowhere again no you
can't you can go to f5 you can sacrifice
the C pawn and get to f7 and win the
Bishop because you as you pointed out
the bishop is the right color corner so
King f5 and when the bishop moves back
again you play a c7 exactly yeah
the king of fight okay okay so thanks
man he's messing it up he might almost
see a draw I think it's a draw I think
okay she's seven and it's a win no but I
think they've had that position three
times what like yeah he it wasn't one
but I'm saying but okay it was a win
though he eventually Tigers it out it
just took forever
you know we agreed that the position is
winning okay I thought you were arguing
that black was drawing no I think
they've had the position three sorry I
don't mean to get angry with you I was
just like Oh whites winning though
you're right okay yeah he eventually
will get here and that was actually kind
of instructive right the the
back-and-forth of the King and Bishop
trying to block in on the dark squares
but eventually it is broken down I don't
know why Grichuk repeated it I mean
you're right Robert if due to head press
the draw button what it'd have been a
draw did they repeat three times I don't
know I lost track but that it felt like
yeah then they were repeating that
position several times at least twice I
mean probably I agree because c7 was was
an option several times and and he
eventually eventually finds it but you
know for those wanting to take away the
instructive elements of that right you
could see the the bishop being the right
color corner of the queening square as
Robert pointed out talking about the
blockade wanting wanting to be on a
diagonal where you can guard both a
promotion square and a potentially key
sort of block hating or barrier square
where your opponent is stuck these are
things you can learn and evaluate in
your own op Scott bishop endings so I
love how people get so excited when we
fight they have no idea about our
relationship they have no idea what we
do off camera I could just say it like
any good marriage you're right we do
fight then you know what we're committed
to the same goals which makes
disagreements easy to overcome wow that
was deep it's true though virtual huh
stop
all right well okay Grichuk just one
that's that's what what just happened
and that obstacle Bishop ending where
maybe due to how to draw and where does
that put us in terms of the the match
well seven six Chris shook and how much
time we've left in this portion like
twenty minutes or something so I was
laughing at Bigfoots comment about our
divorce
um the say that again what I was warning
how much time's left in the three minute
port okay I'll check yeah we've got a
yes I was looking Hikaru parm of perugia
all chatting in the chest TV chat so
very strong player according according
to to our stat guy who literally worked
super hard behind the scenes we like to
make fun of stat boy but my Klein lives
for helping make make make me not sound
as idiotic as I normally am by giving
giving us things to say but he said that
he's 98% he'll check but he's pretty
sure that there was no three move
repetition so whether or not Sasha
realized that or not is another debate I
still think he waited too long to play
c7 but mike says he doesn't think that
there was a draw missed by dude Oh
gotcha
this position looks familiar this is a
reminiscent of Duty's best game right
this pawn structure where double pawns
for black on the F file white having the
opportunity to expand the good thing
that we should did is by playing f6 to
f5 he prevented it white from getting an
easy e 4f4 stuff in which was a huge
problem yeah for him last time and now
white it struggles to play e4 but you
also don't necessarily have to play for
you for it you can play for Knight a
four to c5 if it trades the bishops
first but then I can come there it is
going to c5 any queenless position you
say okay look at your pawn shops there's
black you can't you that my to stop your
three on the right no Queen side and
your double pollens looking a bit iffy
and we also take the dynamic of night
against Bishop into account
because the bish 1d6 is very well placed
you know obviously operates on both
sides of the boards but in end games it
can be very tricky when your bishop can
only see in the dark squares in my
knight comes our poking and prodding at
your in light sweaters right so it's
certainly something to keep in the back
your mind
well whites whites not giving up
obviously you highlighted the Crick put
a put the kibosh on e4 but the whole
purpose of rook 81 I would like to play
for F 384 to get that breakthrough not
just because it would sort of get a
central majority going but the position
opens up might actually help get
attacking chances against the black king
and we have yet again another opposite
side castle in game which just brings in
this dynamic element we've talked about
so many times right of under time
pressure both Kings might be under under
assault and and Duda dude is not gonna
walk away from me for right he knows he
knows uh he knows what he wants when he
sees it
yep yeah I mean right now he wants to
even this match up because he took the
lead for the first time and immediately
dropped it and all right so please g3
not as black you must be doing maybe
just once
h4 just gonna kind of play tickle for a
little bit before he fully commits to e4
or E or he's just all in on your
positional approach coming back to try
to get the ponies off might go to that
full dynamic that you said which is
night versus Bishop yeah we're we're new
blacks pieces go that's the real
question when we talk about improving
our position and evaluating we also are
talking about the future of the board so
Queen a4 at some point it's extremely
tempting because I don't much sure how
you're gonna protect your a5 on to play
rook a8 seems a little bit too passive
for my liking
am i playing you know f4 you're really
trying to get efore in in the near
future and there is e4 he goes now you
have to trade or are you losing material
did he big risk just missed that I mean
okay he gets t4 but that seemed like a
super dangerous thing go home I guess I
was wrong I thought c6 was hanging in
and I never forgot about the d3 night
thing he would check so yeah so actually
maybe he didn't miss it at all
maybe black is doing just fine yeah
Knight takes d6 you just go Queen 66 and
we trade everything on e7 I take on c6
that looks okay from black and here
after Knight f2 what is okay so
threatening rook deewana one of the rook
to one of those squares or both of them
probably aren't good yeah either either
would get the job done winning a piece
on d6 I think so good f5 all right f5
rube d2 I go Queens no but then I had my
end game looks ugly I was a rookie to
Queen c4 we trade Queens my Knights
pindani 4 so they stick on be searched
the rook UF takes d4 but I've always
terrible pawns and more work out yeah
he's not able to he's struggling to
coordinate against the threats of the
Queen being awkward the bishop being
under fire still under attack even on c5
by the night look at that move though
and that was really nice Bishop c5 can't
take it with the pendulum e-file barely
no thanks now he less rook takes e4 oh
and you could see from his sort of
exaggerated exasperated sigh that that
was not what he wanted
so Brooke e2 is never up takes d4 here I
guess so you want to make I was you know
a very nice counter shot looking at
another pin oh speaking of pins rook
takes e5 I was saying gonna say 96 was
necessary before going into this he lost
a very important pawn that was your
pastor then our rook takes a 5 and now
White's the one with the passage on the
Queen side Wow yeah I nearly found the
right way to simplify white should be in
a much better spot now although ok oh I
was in a huge turnaround I mean Grichuk
grishnak is in the driver's seat to
pieces for the rook makes a blunder and
now now making faster 94 check is coming
did you not see it
well he just took this decided this was
probably better say okay ace hey but
who's whose pawns are better
Bishop G ones could be six yep Knight d7
might be seven I see 500 K so you got to
get the King in first here comes a six
game over a seven and when what in the
world
Grichuk shakes his head and Duda shakes
his head neither player deserved to win
that game that was crazy
no Chloe he just missed that the pin on
the the on the fourth-ranked h5 was a
bad move as Scarlett Evans points out 96
was necessary Robert you were right and
we I see someone saying Evo went from
minus 5 to plus 10 in the last few moves
so goes to show that restrict one from
winning to losing in a jiffy and look at
this we have a very sharp Sicilian
poisoned pawn variation yep and okay if
you're playing this is a black you have
to know it there's no excuse otherwise
you're playing it is white you should
know it but maybe you're you know I mean
restrict that Flay knows please what
he's doing
right well they are speaking too soon as
these ever think you don't play these
openings without really being
well-prepared at the highest level nope
and that's why they're taking their time
already Grichuk is Greek is thinking
about similar experiences probably a
little bit of prep to go with it again
from just a sharpness perspective both
sides playing to win chess here we have
had very few draws so they both get full
credit for that got a comp ski what
advise do to avoid the Sicilians against
Erick but but he fears no man yeah look
at this pawn structure
I mean f6 Easton's d6 e6 you are up the
pawn as black but the Queen on e5 is a
great piece if this Knight can just inch
up one Square to see for black pretty
much resigned on the spot
oh not actually but it would be terrible
position but that's the point at night
SC 3 is not doing its best like you
a little bit more active with it the
problem is it takes a while right to get
from C 3 to the C 4 square you're doing
91 93 and if you could put 293 in one
turn then your three Knights c4 and
Knight g4 so White's mission would dress
you know really improve there but I keep
wanting Knight a for Knight b6 as I've
been highlighting Oh a 496 also looks
good that's miss I I'm a little more
biased to these structures as black
frankly uh playing and playing tonight
orphan and the poisoned pawn positions
despite my fears of playing Grusha
given that when you have the bishop pair
on these Center pawns it just I don't
know I just I like black I always want
d5 to come in put my bishop on d6 and
keep the keep the party going yep and I
just saw Hikaru
you know we give hick our lot of shouts
because when the best players in the
world he's competing in this very event
he said back over the board sasha is a
beast when he's low on time but
seemingly not with the mouse and just
goes to show there is a difference
between over the board blitz and online
bliss just mouse skills really come into
play right so Bishop on da doing well to
cover the beasts neck square who wants
to go to c7 to get the d5 idea I talked
about yep but again I think that may be
objectively computers would think that
White's doing fine here blacks king is
in the center and certainly black has
some different pollen islands but from a
practical point of view white has just
as many pawn weaknesses to speak of it's
very difficult to keep these bishops
from kind of getting off their leash
than these types of positions and
usually white just doesn't have enough
minor pieces to mount anything serious
against the black King so again speaking
from biased experience having played a
lot more of these positions as black in
the poisoned pawn if I'm not getting
mated with all the pieces on the board I
usually feel pretty good with my Queen
on e5 and maybe on that note white needs
to play for something like Knight B to
Knight c4 and go over to d6 I don't know
or might be six and try to force black
to give up the bishop because then
that's what he's gonna do because of the
threat of my c4 yeah because might be
two would probably melon d5 I think now
is the right time to do that
okay so you get one Bishop off the board
but again it's a simple position which
makes the the King kind of okay in the
center
yeah can you eat exactly q7 is possible
and the big thing is Queen on e5 is so
strong you can't go Queen g3 with weight
now Queen h3 is tempting there it is
Queen takes d4 Bishop 3 happens
automatically that was key I think rook
h8 might have been a little unnecessary
you can you could try to play h5 here I
mean you're giving up okay you go I
actually like that because you're giving
up the H pawn but kind of a typical
night or fweh you're once white gets
distracted you're gonna play d5 play
King d6 and try to just use your big
center pawn majority which is how black
gets compensation in these end games
yeah Bishop takes h5 you do have
ricocheted right as is none not enough
time to pressure that d7 square yeah I
like that move and and Grichuk doesn't
even want the pawn what's the idea of on
Bishop f3
Oh back rank I made a blunder again
because we've seen either blunder pieces
in this match but now of course Ruby a
trophy a trophy a queen a 1 and there's
a background check man so isn't due to
now just up a pawn and making some sort
of progress I uh I just have to like
blacks positions and I think again
strategically if White's not getting
access points on the different sides of
the board causing the dysfunction that
should be happening when you leave your
King in the center obviously the King
can be target but you're supposed to
lack coordination right the pieces on
both sides of the board they don't quite
come together and these scenarios black
has a centralized Queen very aggressive
play on the Queen side and just moving
forward we just got a big donation in a
shout out thanks to Danny Andra $63.99
bringing it to an even 3100 thanks to
Danny and Robert for always giving us a
great show what a match thank you
the players appreciate your love - yeah
absolutely it's going to their pocket
and I'm lovin I'm loved
again this has been such a back and
forth affair right Duda gets his first
league Grichuk wins two games in a row
Duda wins a game he probably shouldn't
have last game with this you know -
Brooks versus the minor swindle but but
now he's about to win a pretty clean
game at least he's much better I won't
say black is gonna win yet but he's much
better here and a pretty clean game from
start to finish and the poisoned pawn
Knight or if Colin comps keys Bluff
willing to play the Sicilian it gets
Grichuk you know
look Ashley this is I just I know I've
been biased I just love I love the way
Black has played this game yeah I think
we're sugars made some I don't was a
carat Queen age six always nice to get
in a chance he wants rookie one he wants
to simplify just wait five vision H five
you have to equate our queen of six
check mediate though at the end yeah I
guess I've no more never be one so
Bishop age five Queen age five Queen f6
King a rook b1 okay maybe that could be
that could be crazytown because we're
k-8 you might even have rookie seven no
you don't have rookie seven I would have
a queen d1 check ah um actually no then
I have no follow-up checks so you might
have that would I don't know that might
have been crazy
he has queen chief I live all or queen
g3 Krish it just misses it and he's
going down right that see I mean that
looked like and you know after the
opening Greg needed to play quickly he
did not play quickly and h5 was a very
nice response but I do that when his h7
paw was under attack and unfortunately
for Agra shook he just didn't use the
initial very well and was yeah that
wasn't ideal that wasn't ideal in terms
of the finish there shout-out to Frank
Rutan subscribing for four months in a
row we love you Frank
at chess calm but wow what it what a
great comeback again two victories in a
row and a very very nicely played game
you're right obviously okay Grichuk
didn't necessarily play the best Knight
or poisoned pawn but still just keeping
his head about him and do to do to play
with the big boys
yep he's afraid of nobody
nobody and now we got a big big donation
from the the the queen of chess at least
as far as chess shows are concerned
chess BAE coming through with five
thousand bits sending some energy to
grishnak she's letting it be known she's
rooting for Sasha what's going on in
this game Nike
okay so Queen takes d5 so at five f3 as
possible
let's beat her I like B three better
because there's no reason to ruin your
own pawn structure this f2 to d4
punching is very strong and we're
playing f3 you give black a target on
the e3 square so instead trying to
coordinate the pieces we see - I'm
always looking out for a potential
sacrificing these four square I don't
see it working just yet so back to the
clean up to seventh this was the
structure he had earlier word we really
like black and I don't feel like it's as
good as it was in that game where he
just punched at four through and won the
d4 pawn for those of you who've been
with us but it still still seems like
black out the best out of the opening
now that the C pawn is guarded Robert
what's stopping my me from playing 97-95
putting a piece on this nice square
nothing stopping here and that's what's
happening 97 that stop at us now right
wait we weren't singing together sorry I
wanted to be serenaded I don't want to
do it do it the better
all right viscera for here comes the c-4
square the best way to counteract blacks
control over the white squares but you
got to watch out for c5 c5 comes for
black then the pieces come to life I
think I think that's what he's going for
with King AJ getting off the checks
really wants to be in a position to play
c5 here if you can yes a Bishop c4
prevents c5 because I take on e6 and
I'll be able to take on c5 so it just
makes playing c5 is definitely good for
black and freeing other pieces it also
helps white in some regard because it
opens the defy allows the Knights just
hop to c4 and you know that's a that is
progress for white as well and I just
want to point out as my client just
mentioned to me there have been 15 games
and zero draws which has to
be a record and yes I mean I I spoke too
soon in saying that we had never had a
completely decisive five minute or ssin
but as smarter just told us
Fabio Caruana and holy faun last year
did just that but have we ever had this
many games in a row with not a single
draw like in the history of the universe
kind of thing it's pretty crazy yeah
it's exciting
okay he settles on c6 which for now
isn't c5 but given that he's up a lot on
time has the bishop pair I think
grishnack is feeling kind of comfy here
he's really scooted himself back up
again you know what's the latest ingress
Chuck's armpit the way he's just backed
up but we are getting a pretty nice view
of griffix left side which is his good
side I've been told so at least he's got
that going bishop e8 watch out for g5
Bishop d6 + f4
this could be coming yeah definitely an
over the clock situation what's going on
there 24th is that a pawn no Swain -
look at me I'm like that little kid who
sees a squirrel squirrel
you're like free Oreo I'm like free
Orioles get in my van sorry that was
wrong but you know you get the dog on up
squirrel so 95 I don't like age 5 by
Chris chick though oh yeah why didn't he
go for my plan now all the sudden that
dark stores are closing down and I'm and
I'm loving whites whites uh approaching
in yeah and actually why does a shot to
open things up with Knight a5 and d5
making these the fact the c8 rook is not
defended enough huh there's 95 step 1
and b5 is okay I like to send you to try
to trade the bishops but Bishop all
right is a fled Bishop a - but there's
we need to know now maybe people I can
get b6 I don't know why he waited I feel
like you wanted to give her this night
while you could
she ate the bag didn't say a word
I thought bisher makes you and put the
Queen on b3 like this is the reverse
that Knight to c4 but but then what runs
Brooke Paige I think he's just sitting
tight because of the time at this point
yeah we're in that sort of could flip a
coin ground this may end up being our
last three minute game depending on how
long this goes I'm guessing is the
second the last game and this time
control just based on how little time
but he's hanging in there
so play just make a move right it's all
you have to do is just make a safe move
Fischer beat you yeah fitting the knight
back White has to sit tight and just
make sure you play fast enough with the
time now that the be pawns been pushed
you can double rooks on the C file
exactly and this is kind of an
instructive point cuz that's why you
sort of poke and prod these pause and
say come on move forward now down white
can play rook H 2 c1 why is he losing
why is he taking so much time
yeah I think he's afraid of any time
bishop ACH for stuff but I agree with
you that yes you just put what she's
wanting I think you got to put rotation
c1 play Bishop C now or visually 6 do it
Christians not gonna say he should not
sacrifice nature I think objectively
it's a wrong decision to take on h4 and
so it he wasn't gonna do it all so why
did ya what is KH 6 now what does that
doing there to go g5 I guess I think
critics just might be three it might be
3 Queen takes before maybe was possible
I was trying to pull in there and c5 but
your right knee sorry gobbling up on my
palm 9 I think we're coming
I believe really gonna pledge c5 through
I see oh don't go 95 is blundering
ambition 182
Queen g2 44 seconds for Chris Chuck he's
got to decide do I sit she probably can
hold on time or do I play Chi 5 and try
to flag him in the attack definitely
would have played g5 yeah I think you
should have played g5 while you still
had the LightSquared bishop something
crazy could happen to this king on h6
here oh my gosh he goes for h4 h4
Oh rookie never would have stopped at
all they still stopping it
so where's your Nikon just can't
Stoddard eh file you can only hope
contain it he's gonna he's gonna come
back at some point this h-file becomes a
problem
well now King comes in g2 in fact I
might love that 4yp what why didn't it
work on g5 is overloaded it's gonna come
back to save the deep against the deep
on and the king right the king is gonna
have six rook takes h5 uh okay but still
still move em in the right decision okay
just don't back up I get the King in
front of the D pawn here girls working
six and now if you play Brooke f6 a
Brooke g5 King e5 right oh he should
have played King e5 there what is he
doing he's gone forward the oven he's
enough he's like a passed pawn he's in
the Queen side he has enough that's the
mathematical evaluation of how many pass
policies he has enough but the problem
is it's not how many pass pawns you have
a su Queens first in these end games and
there goes and there it goes
rook with a potentially okay Kanda
Brooke stop these pawns this is one of
those give you a heart attack positions
I've lost more of these than I'd like to
talk about on both sides like who's
mastered Nevin rip d8 g6 seems like
black is gonna do it just in time
because the mating net white steam is
gonna get okay assuming black and figure
out the right checks to play here yeah
check on d2 with the rook swing the
Queen to g1 and you've got it I don't
know if that was the best but he's gonna
get clean before okay we need 2777 show
counts the opponent's over and drown we
should have just done it but he's gonna
meet him instead I like this rook me too
oh my gosh I was so stressed out there
it was like it was my game probably
didn't need to keep the Ebell bar go in
there everyone sorry about that but
normally in those times crambles I
changed the view but it looks like
they're gonna get one more 3-minute game
I can tell Grichuk being such a pro in
this time control knows that that may
not be the case so he's checking before
he restarts but it looks like it looks
like we will have one more game indeed
Wow barely one more game yep and smarter
chess is busy being happy that
you know this has been tight match and
estimations have been pretty close to
being accurate
yeah and Mach 62 motocross still no
draws much still no draws 16 games deep
they should go on somebody's grave stone
still no draws 16 games deep and at this
point they would have to have a draw if
they're gonna continue on dudas pattern
which is that he had a tied match
heading into the bullet versus Sergey
Karjakin right and Wow well I'm told
that as per our announced plans right
now is the end of our raffle last chance
to enter the raffle if you are a
subscriber at twitch TV slash chess go
ahead and enter the command because we
are going to do the giveaway in about 30
seconds in fact let's let's do it at the
end of this game so as soon as this game
is over and the three-minute portion
comes to an end we will reveal our
winner of today's merge contest
thank you everyone regardless of whether
you're playing in the raffle or not for
being here and watching what is turning
out to be one of the best matches we've
had in a long time
yep and I love this comment in the chest
I compte be chat from niala Soren says
Duda is only twenty said the 14 year
olds yeah B house already just became
one of the youngest GM's of the world
yeah it's pretty awesome to see him you
know cheering on I don't know he's
rooting for him but just watching this
chess and you know clearly an incredible
talent but just was really funny hearing
something was younger you know as a
teenager say oh he's only twenty the
young and the young and he's like 14
year old oh he's just a kid
just a kid that Duda smashed Bob
Squarepants just jumping in the raffle
this is your last game last chance to
subscribe and jump on our raffle for
today we appreciate the support all
right well this is as close as a
position we've had in a while the anti
Sicilian poison pollen from last game
with the Queen on e5 so where do we go
from here what do we got here
I just trying to mislead Oh standing
there trying to make us think that this
is gonna be a draw because it's all
closed
right going on and there's something
Crazy's gonna happen and you know in
time travel someone's little dudes yeah
this is yes I mean look at this a four
we gonna get a three in a real locked up
situation here no I think you'll but
Bishop of two and there it is he wants
touchy or Bishop III of five I really
would have considered moved my king over
the Queen side first so King up to King
he - but g4 and I try to expand for
white on the King side and said he goes
the C files he's trying to be three of
b3 and C for another maybe even better
idea given that Duda has kind of fully
committed the King to this direction of
the board put on his running shoes yeah
and it's important to note that the
reason why why trying to open up the
position is there's a extra bishop in
whites army this LightSquared bishop and
so the bishop needs open space it can't
just be sitting behind walls and Pont
yep that's him
I'm still not convinced that Y will be
able to open the position enough in a
useful way I mean at some point if you
play b3 you can try to take eight then
you're gonna go for c4 and this look a
bit scary so I don't know a black can
really has to prove that he's in
position to ward off these mice yet and
that's a big problem with this structure
we almost went this entire match without
talking about a French we haven't talked
about the French opening but now we're
talking about a French structure where
as Robert said the big issue for black
is that he's he's kinda at the mercy of
White's plan right is white gonna go for
g4 now five and do your pieces need to
be coordinated enough to deal with the
Kings side becoming open or is white
cannot organize B 3 and C 4 and do your
pieces need to be coordinated to deal
with the light squares opening there so
again it's it's you know it's a solid
looking position for black but it's just
a difficult one to play if I was to add
add even more just you know jumping on
top of the point you made there Robert
Wright does that's the difficulty from
being black here on a practical level
yeah 100% and you're b3 at some point is
what white wants there but white may
regroup and go over to the H file yeah
there you go
here comes h5 and black is sort of
trying to trying to play a very tough
balancing like now you're risking on
force on including a weakness on g6 but
even if even if white doesn't go for it
you haven't totally
lost full flexibility to eventually
build and play on that side of the board
so we'll see if if grishnak wants what
does Richard deal with his camera right
now it looks like he just he's given us
a piece of his mind with his fists here
apparently I don't know he's slamming me
well there's position I can definitely
backfire for white again but just now he
just opened the a file
yeah the a files open some premature for
white to do that trying to think in the
exact way when whence may promise if the
rook where I'm be - you could play Queen
c2 to attack g6 and encourage at five so
your knight can jump into e5 but if
you're black you know rook a3 that's an
empire b2 so it doesn't exactly make
progress I actually like the plan you
just said of rook B - anyway put the
Queen on c2 to try to induce exactly
what you're talking about if I can get
the F pawn to push then e five is my new
home oh oh do to place it he voluntarily
and Here Come c4 okay somebody's getting
mated on the light squares here and you
know just stay buckled up right we're
gonna have a happy ending for somebody
so you're a problem and you know it
everyone loves when the end of the game
is happy if they're on the winning side
that's all that's all I meant
rook rook to a1 we can double on the C
file or open up right away all right
takes b5 can i sack give me a second let
me beat you on the light squares come on
no you know what I wanted by the way if
I sample c7 Robert E six also falls so
I'm not crazy now I definitely think
it's a worthwhile idea and he's going to
come improve his gonna play slowly but
at some point this night will fall in as
I said someone's getting made it on the
light squares someone's getting made it
on the light squares tonight Queen did
was look at this many times e1 yep
gobble
this is why you don't slay the French
one of many reasons what have Betty
reasons why Queen goes back to e to or
trade at this point now that you have
Harry over here
there shouldn't be a problem for for
white to just in fact the night is
already in a position to to help Harry
become a real wizard and this nice
trying to go to Mexico for very quickly
and which is certainly a good enough
queen name but it's still too slow I can
just trade I'll be too yeah then you're
always a queen see to close off yep
yeah ranks and now here comes again just
advanced okay each six to the nine of
six so the very least that's a nice move
back to you five he'll play aged six
oh no a bloody Queen C six but where's
the follow-up no meet yet don't meet yet
you're right that's coming age seven
though not 497 Queen Center sweet is
stuck he's still blundered it I'm sure
he just lucky the queen is guarding the
bishop age seven wins immediately yeah
Knight is stuck to d7 and we have made
on the board
oh but Nana's it hurts it hurts to be
this good says Sasha crook he's probably
gonna check in with us now make sure
it's a break yep I I didn't mean to say
I told you so but if I know anything I
know Sasha well Robert we've seen a
super exciting match it's a one game
lead for Grichuk Hikaru Nakamura said
Grichuk needed a lead in bullet if he
was gonna win the match stay tuned
everybody don't go anywhere we're gonna
find out in about a minute or two
exactly who is the best at the fastest
time control the speech has championship
format has to offer
and we'll be right back and while we may
have forgotten to give away our reveal
or raffle winner before the break we
have not forgotten about the raffle I'm
sorry about that was a little bit caught
up in the excitement of the moment fifty
five hundred of you here now which means
we have everybody waiting around for not
just the exciting moment of who's gonna
win our raffle right now but who's gonna
win this match so let's do it
let's do the reveal giveaway the raffle
and remember that even if you don't win
the merge we're giving away any merch
today sends an increased price fund
directly into the pockets of the player
so here we go
raffle go I don't know how to do it
somebody behind the scenes go for it
Robert winner is and the winner is me no
no but I win
I didn't even you're not allowed to
enter you're not allowed to enter so
there we go
who won I don't even know good one looks
like who won I don't know how do I know
chess Baywood how rigged is that I mean
it was not Rea what what are the chances
of that like that give me a second let's
give away a second prize not because
that wasn't completely random and the
most amazing thing ever but it is I've
never done one of these before it is a
thousand percent random right I'm pretty
sure that is so awesome
all right well what is what is even more
awesome is what a rune yeah there we go
we just give us a so we get away - we're
gonna - of rune a rune u.s. ck you have
also just one summer stood a thank you
to everybody report and unsubscribe
reported and unsubscribe funny Clayton
or clay turn yeah it was totally weird
apparently karma is real and the more
you give the more you get just bay 94
wins the the raffle and all the matters
is now we're moving on so the bullet it
begins
even more exciting than the raffle we
have a one-game match let's go let's go
let's go
bullet show here we go and I'm wondering
you when do two takes over the black
pieces if we'll see him play the French
like he did against Kuryakin in the
bullet portion yeah yeah here here we go
both sides playing quickly in this night
or and alright castle both sides Castle
kingside I know my client was talking
about how that was yeah the very third
time out of you know what is it 17 games
now
yeah and alright so this line d5 is
under control for now or simply because
you can
f6r it is essential that pond d6 is a
backward pawn y can start piling up the
pressure Queen d2 rope do you want at
cetera Bishop takes b3 you tend not so I
want to make them move because Bishop b3
pawn takes yes you give white some
double pawns but you also release your
control over the d5 square and now after
Knight d5 you play C c3 or c4 you didn't
wanna play c4 too early because the
Knight d4 is a potential response I
guess for black yep and look at the time
situation due to up to 10 seconds here
Knight f6 Queen f6 Queen takes d6 and
there's a 58 you couldn't take on b3
right away because your six was hanging
and he might go go for with a three but
here come these arms come here come the
New York alarms which is maybe a sign
for Duda that he shouldn't have taken
that pond we'll find out if it was
poisoned or not but he doesn't good yo
you're right he gets out gets out and
all Bishop takes b3 is now is a trade to
the second rank but for whites up a
healthy pawn was Queen oh yeah yeah why
don't we Queen takes me 7
I'll do it now but he just missed it it
was even stronger before it certainly
was we're saying with the rook on a4 you
know just could have come into the yeah
I think he sometimes you win a pawn and
then psychologically you're just kinda
happy that you've calculated accurately
he decides I'll play a quick defensive
move and that happens right Robert right
Robert I mean psychologically sometimes
you win a pawn and then you know you
don't realize your full opportunity to
kind of put your foot on their throat
right yeah Queen b6 I mean I mean it
guards f2 and advances but this position
isn't nearly as good as it could have
been for white now you don't really want
to take because black is bringing even
more firepower to the second rank yep
and so using the queen but not rook
takes t3 that nice coming in to d4 yeah
this is you boy he's not gonna be happy
about this is backfired he really
panicked with this unnecessary kind of
passive approach me shaking his head now
kind of knows it I'm doing I feel like
every time they make a mistake somebody
in the chat whether it's on chesty of
your twitch says maybe it was a mouse
slip I don't think so okay just a better
end game from black because well that's
on but I wasn't saying here without c2
though it Oh
rook C to Bishop III I can't win f2 in
time okay but e for at some point for
black followed by kind of relocating the
knight and rook to work together on this
week pawn on the dark square this is
gonna be a tough endgame for white to
hold I mean pretty ridiculous that white
went from up a pawn a clean pawn to down
upon no we called it right he wasn't
playing aggressively enough ended but it
got really bad really quickly here comes
e4 as we said now you'll either trade on
e3 and then focus on Chi 3 here's your
target in these end games everyone or
you or you'll try to just relocate the
knight and rook to work on f2 and g1 as
is
yeah I think he's gonna try to play
blues like rook c7 or Brooke it no
rookie Brooke c7 was better because the
bishop actually guards a to camp or 1993
King g5 King g5 here rook c8 check King
age sevens the only move take g6 and g7
that h3 check teenage five I just take
on you seven take on f5 and it's like
finish the draw I mean well I might even
be better now Knight each one you see
traveling is Oh knight always got the
wrong color bishop exact lassic classic
Sasha swindling swindling the draw and
as I do to shake his hands in the first
draw by the way yeah first draw the
entire match happens in the first game
of bullets so if you if you thought you
were gonna see exciting chess today you
were right and those those are still
funny about chess pay the chest may had
a three percent chance of winning the
raffle alright so let it go and we did a
second one just to just to prove that we
wanted to give away more but it was not
rigged like we said maybe maybe corn was
real maybe the more you give the more
you get but she had a three percent
chance and I see Peter dockers and the
chest TV chat saying wouldn't be funny
if all of these games ended in a draw
and he also said that before that first
game was drawn so yeah he's running from
bullet says more to come more to come
with the truss and if anyone knows Peter
knows yeah you know not because he draws
all the time but because he's uh
obviously an esteemed chest cause all
the time
I'll just say
you know I did it there should be no
fishery for Knight c3 you have to play
Bishop e4 because of Queenie for the
rook goes to e1 but before Knight c3 if
you take on f3 I take on d5 and take any
7 with check and I win a piece and if
tonight
if you move Queen a5 they take on e4
anyway and play rook you 100 I wouldn't
do to just blowed it a piece yep don't
be surprised if we're looking at that
beautiful view of Sasha's neck for the
rest of the the shell so he's played in
a few of these matches but it doesn't
mean he's any better at telling me now
I'm like I tell him now lean in do that
thing where you lean in and show me
where you're gonna be he's like I'm
gonna be right here I'm like no you're
not I will say that thinking for so long
and resigning was not to strategy what
Blackshear done is Trust sacrificed the
Queen for two minor pieces and actually
were getting very decent chances in a
bullet game so he could have put Bishop
takes e4 nicely Bishop takes f3 and I
thought you either play quickly and
recognize the blunder knowing it's
bullet or you resign immediately because
you need every time every second you can
on the total game clock with 24 minutes
we have our first two game lead for
either player that we've had and what
more than since the beginning of the
match yeah we shook went up 4 to 1 and
then since then it's been pretty
neck-and-neck
so yeah been a long time since well a
lot of people felt like Duda was the
favorite and bullet including Hikaru so
right now Sasha Sasha proving everybody
wrong right yeah I mean gross Suga is a
obviously a good bullet player and
remember he had a funny interview last
time where he was like oh you should
allow someone who should resign right
that's right son
okay White's gaining space here the d4
square of course black can plug that
night in there but whether that's
sufficient rook b1 to avoid a knight b3
check and just developing the men in d5
is strong the 94 is also strong but you
might be 5 a4 oh that's an exchange yeah
that's that's a whole
change Grichuk kind of nodding oh oops
and there goes the ape on a four a four
a five rook comes in deadly fire needs
this wit yeah the ninety five improved
more powerful than than in d4 because
there was a check in the position that
was available so just a Gumby six or
working one first I mean doesn't really
but black actually has a later II
slightly okay this is nice but black has
a slightly irritating position to break
okay miss Bishop g5 check yes I would
have one material with the rook on d8
now it doesn't girl but it's still
winning yeah and only twenty seconds
from fish like looks like looks like
time and remember glam during twenty
seven is right and proving me wrong that
I said grishnack is proving everybody
wrong and that he's doing well in bullet
and he said he hasn't proven anything
yet it's only been two games and I guess
he's right because now polish fire
fights right back and we have a one game
match once again and here's the Sicilian
he gets rid of the Petrov and goes for
these the night off here and nobody in
g5 okay so ethical mission for the
g5 line said puts that Bishop right back
home on c1 and then now with upon aged
six white wood is hoping that that
difference is good for him in the sense
that the g6 square can sometimes be
Bowman but if you play f4 f5 and take on
e6 harder to take back with the F pawn
on e6 in these lines I think black is
totally fine in the early stages of this
game though look at the clock situation
yeah and early eight second lead now now
this blacks move sparing a bit of time
but still I think blacks position is
quite solid here okay this is a typical
way to attack this structure and in a
time on our first chef inning and kind
of Sicilian everyone we've got this
undermining of the d5 pawn you hope now
you play e5 thinking if you can keep
this structure together you have long
term attacking chances on the Kings side
but black is solid right you've got
you've got like a good French pawn
structure right you've got a solid pawn
chain but none of the none of the really
bad
what no such thing has ever say good
French again yeah wash my mouth out
later daddy Rekha Rove Cup is silho I
can play the bishop back to be one
you've got ideas of the battery on the
Kings side you can play a four to five
but it's a really double-edged way to
approach the position every pawn you
pushed leads to maybe weak dark squares
if the attack fails so okay Queens you
for makes sense you want to defend a
five okay now now you can even play
Bishop c1v g5 i play immediately there
it is a ship c1 should have been played
for sure instead of king h1 that was
that was the move the Queen e2 retreat
is smart because not f4 comes at the
tempo or Bishop c1 if you want okay
we're really careful here because right
now these bishops don't seem like much
but they're sleeping ninjas over there
and he's inviting f6 saying b3 pawn is
more important than what seems like an
attack the faster probably you know
ignore ignore it so Grichuk believes him
d4 do it d4 submit the bishop and then
gets c5 in the seat life or white play
c5 always sees it the positional
counter-strike Bishop on a e8 totally
trapped and that Bishop means to run
back into the game very quickly this is
this is a problem for black Bishop
Bishop d7 is Bishop no there's not
business we can play Queen c4 here move
the bishop off at five this looks really
good for white
okay so Queen 65 that's a pawn you
should have you should have played the
Queen c4 idea we were talking about yeah
lady six here I guess if you're white
trying to say ten ways hey get a six
takes Bishop takes I was oh here comes
the c5 no see five move e5 now good move
yeah gain the temple boom Queen G ba six
he's threatening though yo I was
threatening Queen takes h6 yeah I wanted
to go Queen G fiber than you took took
upon eise evans and i've been a blunder
so now play this is this has definitely
been miss played by grishnak so far
Queen Queen c4 was much better than the
approach that dropped the C pawn back
back a few moves ago
so it six is just spawned Bishan before
oh and then take take workup six no it
doesn't work
rookie you oh wait was it know the c7
check - sure lights quirky - mate Ricky
- III yep Oh
- strong Grichuk was too weak too slow
and Duda Dudus showing a lot of people
why he why he was the favorite and the
bullet portion and I mean I don't even
know if anything describes it as well as
what we can see right here our graphs
tell us everything we need to know we
have a back and forth affair another
super exciting match we have had we have
had our fair share of matches that could
go either way in the last portion this
year on the speeches championship so
that's nice yep does that mean
tight as it can be so here we see that
look at look at Duda taking upon saying
you know I'll accept it and you maybe
come to attack me over here on the
queenside but you really have to prove
it because then I could take on g7 as he
does yep and take on the phone I can
move knight g-33 Knight a5 check at the
right moment there is 93 but black
clearly has compensation here it's not
like it's a Geoffrey Pont for whites he
hasn't the tag this is common tactic you
can't take with the cheap on because the
Queen gets everybody with check but if
you don't take it Queen h6 it usually
comes to follow any way or even Queen
qi5 yeah he goes with the the latter I
like it Queen g5 the Knights gonna
retreat now we can move our Knight to a
number of squares he chooses e7 you know
why sufficient well he's a bishop takes
a - there's no Queen your Queen
cattleman h4 h5 that's what's coming
you're gonna make a hell yeah I dude I
am all about Harry's journey here forget
we forget the rook I don't even care
h5 and I'm gonna meet you on the H 5 H 5
yes this is what I wanted Latricia cos
surprised
I'm so glad I got him right now as I am
super excited f6 just pawn to g6
six and it's mate on h7 over and my
flipping bananas work up seven was nice
though the holy holy that was nice
oh man dude I'm like freaking out over
here I love this exchange sack attack
you can see it coming rook f7 just saved
the day
Brooke f7 and somehow white has given up
too much material the rook on Queen or
hanging I don't see a saving I said he
never should have pushed the H pawn I
called it
I mean I'm okay he's threatening mate
Queen takes h7 is mate yeah but now he's
down a full rook rook g8 here oh no Ruby
who runs in a queen takes h7 made again
so don't fall don't don't be myself on
h8 smothered some other self smothered
yes exactly okay now you can do it
there's no Queen takes h7 that's exact
of it now he's got it well I think we've
recovered from the attack that was a
pretty epic scene rook f7 is one of the
best that was one of the best defensive
finds we've had certainly in the match
today maybe maybe the move of the match
here comes rook TV should be was for she
can just take it yeah he goes for you
King Aichi would have run into Queen a5
mate everybody yep wow I thought that
was like Duda winning the third game in
a row super amazing launch of the H pawn
and Grichuk finds rook f7 really it's a
phenomenal one went on here you know
what I'm doing way done I'm spam and
Sasha heads with double X clamps what
else am I supposed to do
[Laughter]
sasha is a fighter and you know he was
shocked right he he could see it in his
face he like was in disbelief that he'd
be up a full rook but yeah really
that was amazing admirable defense by
coming down the wire I agree Bishop to
b5 check in 97 okay so this is
positional edge for white kind of
typical of an early overextended knight
or pawn structure something went wrong
yeah this is nice
three and this is why you don't want to
over extend too quickly because now
white just has a positional edge on the
queenside because those pawns went too
far books are nice throwing some energy
bits toward Grichuk I wish energy bits
were a real thing that would be cool I
mean you're right though about this
position you over send very early which
means that you have to catch up in
development and in the meantime
Khrushchev went for the two bishops and
from whites point of view the from
b5 is so strong because that on a4 and
Bishop protect each other it prevents
black from using any of these squares in
the diagonal you know you can't believe
rooks e6 and up on the C file you can't
play rook e8 if you ever want to so you
can also move that Bishop away from b5
and put a knight on b5 of course that's
an option as well so let's see how can
black Bishop g7 okay that's more than
reasonable so if let's gotten out of
this yeah I think the worse is
definitely behind but C 5 is inducing
Bishop d6 so I can play Bishop oh yeah
that's why I was thinking I'd like it I
see bishop things g3 as well and after
in Bishop c5 there's an exchange sac but
Wow well now we've got a full mix like
this so matinee sacrificing the Kings
side to win both overextended pawns on
the Queen side but he might regret it I
this is this is a pretty open King over
here h5 to support Knight g4 okay h3
makes sense and that just stopping
Brooke c5 to throw that rook over to f5
yeah I like that idea
look at this jump Rose Queen on before
and start poking and prodding I liked
your idea though thank you I appreciate
your support Bishop before wins the
exchange oh but but this is gonna be a
super dangerous ending to pawns on the
Queen side already past its yeah you
know honestly I would have thought about
trading the rooks because Ilana's rook
to be four see ya ya Grisham
instinctively when you're down the
exchange there you
avoid the Rookery but I think you might
be right now you should have if I
simplify it
okay now you wanna uh I think Krisha
should have backed up the bishop bought
b5 you can take them because Jack why
isn't he playing 95 it's a great
question he could you go take it on b5
and taking on a six as well but chose
not to so yes I'll take a matrix I'm
matter anyway which he kind of is but
see now Grichuk allows the rip trade
kind of proving your point but due to
not interested up a pawn in the night
and rook ending oh do this yes he can he
fighting no b5 doesn't work 93 right so
yeah 93 barely gets back so now is king
of sitting you know King moves over at
palm you play off six when the King
comes close yeah although actually if
you keep your King on like c4
oh yeah like this yeah it's a matter of
Tempe here so King B 7 B 6
yeah you can't go for the f5
breakthrough with g4 cuz widel Queen
first so if white just sits tight right
and if black ever pushes them white
abandons the b-pawn and comes back over
here and perhaps even wins the king of
hunting so this this may still end up
being a draw
okay now we're gonna find out that maze
that may be a regrettable decision from
Duda ever well I say hi for oh he
could've went King takes c4 there and
just brought his King back to stop the
pawn king takes before was just winning
he missed it you're right yep now okay
it should be a drug you know the King
can't escape especially the Queen on h1
the King's I go anywhere but yeah he
missed an opportunity agrestic was
winning on king takes e4 neither side
saw it Wow
okay well it's raw nonetheless and you
know from a practical perspective maybe
this was the right decision from
Griffith look how much time he's taking
off the clock and he's up a game you
know yep there's one player who we've
ever had in post speech chess
championship match history that's ever
just openly admitted to us that that's
what he was doing and that was Sasha
gursha
right yep I don't think that's what he
was doing there I think he just I mean
to two games is much more important than
one game lead in that in that scenario
but if Grichuk is in a position to take
time off the total game clock he's a
gamer and he knows what he's doing yeah
you and Danny I'm thinking about it now
when the White King was on c6 that was
probably the time to know there's some
idea I'm trying to figure out there must
been time to go from black to go f5 yeah
first like at some point but yeah just
didn't didn't pan out so okay we see
we've seen this before right we saw how
dude went for the H file while
sacrificing a rook in another game and
here we should goes for an early d5 well
it makes sense with the knight is
misplaced on a3 which you want that I
had c3 to blockade that bishop on g7
with a minute a3 it's out in the
wilderness
yo bishop d4 this Queen h4 check g3 and
then Knight takes every track and you've
Michelin d4 falls so night c2 helps this
bishop prominent before you have to go
to d4 even if you lose b2 with the X
rate and I can take it because the
bishop defends it through the other
you'll take on b2 here right and then
you back to c4
well night c4 I'll take Jenna
Queen C then it makes sense to leave you
with that I say I want to get the rook
t8 before you get cancelled so if I can
play rook e8 you can definitely
recognize I don't know why I think I
think Duda should take him with the
night there so he could have counseled
but I guess he didn't he doesn't want to
get castle that's against his plans
starting to look good from black I was
gonna say I think you might regret this
approach because this is nice before
rook takes you to check you need to
Queen e7 check picks up an item before
oh nice that was very nice rook takes c2
on the Queenie's
if this Queen ever moves from d4 watch
out for Queen h4 check now ah no this is
even just from a practical perspective
of kings in the center and bullet chess
there are usually not a happy couple now
play d4 if you're black cut the Queen
off from h4 guess the good news is
between h4 tech a g1 that new 1 square
is protected barely barely defended off
your right but now here comes the Queen
B pawn I'm gonna hit this a pawn is
going he's gonna rush it it's catch me
if you can out here boy Rose d800e
what does he want he wants a rookie 7
what is he doing what is doing and then
Bishop e4 in fiendish me for was winning
right away yes to play f5 now he is to
stop definitely for he had missed me for
before right yeah I agree I don't know
what Grichuk was doing either though Wow
missed opportunity there but anything
you still should be clean are there any
sacrifice in 87 with the back rank being
weak and watch I never work see one may
is coming yeah there could be a
sacrifice on e7 nice I back Frank is
with white black should play h4 first he
goes back and the knight 93 under my
Nova doesn't know why he did that cuz
now d4 is under fire what is he doing
Queen goes back to g7 this is a little
bit of I'm afraid to blunder in bullet
chess right now yep which is
understandable just rooks e7 Queen d2
check pick up the nighttime before
what's going on here then both they're
both really missing a lot super nervous
right now and this King on h6 is totally
out of his element but grishnack is
winning opponent and and due to has
nothing yep yeah this is this is this is
the kind of this is the time situation
where this could be the match right here
Robert what should have been a win for
white with that incredibly strong a pawn
in a tied match could be a two-game lead
for Grichuk with only 5 minutes to go Oh
watch out Bishop g8 now is a pretty big
threat okay Bishop Jay the King is the
g5 escape but the point is it's really
this game is
a lot of deep one did he he just he just
forgot about time and you could see this
pump there
I mean Grichuk literally pumped his fist
this is why I love this format if only
they could felt their fists in over the
board classical chess that was awesome
peace
what you so upset I've actually heard to
watch that was heartbreak I mean that
was the match I mean he was clearly much
better he knew it he had Bishop before
as you said I think he's this is one of
those moments where what's going on
inside his head right now is he's he's
trying to focus in the moment but you're
just still beating yourself up from the
previous game right oh that hurt to
watch honestly seeing his face yep and I
mean mathematically if this game goes
more than for more than three minutes I
mean the match may be over well I signed
out to he just music win both the next
day he has to win this game and then
start the next game before regulation
time runs out yes as long as the game
starts before the time runs out it does
count toward the total score
wow that is wait what this looks good
from black again what is it I feel like
somehow do this guy never saw some quite
nice positions in the black side of
these Sicilians agreed yeah you can't
take on before with the Queen because in
d5 comes in I was queen eight five here
I mean what is a free attack this is me
I mean Quinn what am I missing Queen a5
wait how you gonna protect a two I guess
you have h6 there but then black boys is
a five I don't I don't know I think I
mean this is still an even this looks
pretty good too and now play cleaning
five yeah now it's even better and
remaining above B - I think Rick is like
what did I do
if he loses this game super quickly
that's a huge favor for Duda right I
mean he can even lose this game but take
enough time off the clock okay Queenie I
mean a queen takes b3o
match saving win he just wanted met with
90 seconds in 90 seconds he just brought
this match into a close
Robert can you feel it yes oh my god
takes me
three like a boss it's funny because I
was trying to go be three for that same
exact purpose of breaking open to be a
father made his Fisher would say yeah
the rock never concedes stuff the main
people aren't crazy in the trash they
should be but they're not spamming the
right emote this is amazing that was the
dude ahead going dogs so look at this
Danny again grow shook goes back to this
you know kind of Kings in Yao pawn
sacrifice lion and I mean dude it have
so many new fans like this you should
two and a half minutes left
you're literally ex magnus carlsen
diamond member says I'm screaming I hope
you're screaming enough you like your
mom here's your downstairs
what are you doing Robert the meat low
mom I'm streaming chess this is great
for white by the way this game yeah
Polish fighter we have not had an
overtime match this year yet c5 was a
brilliant move by that's called
practical counter play I didn't like
castling queenside aus if I should have
taken on d5 but oh look at that return
sacrifice that's peace I love this I
love it the most I love the pressure I
love look at this it should be 595
follows up if you play rube d8 Wow or
see it's actually rip dude there's c6
now this is just winning for white what
a sack this is epic this is so at this
we had one overtime match last year
right Geary versus so yeah this this
would be our first overtime match in the
2018 sec all right in the you know he
knows that he has until you know he's
even if the game clock
you know the match clock and this game
counts no matter what so if he wins this
game we're headed to overtime even if
time runs out yes I know queen me sex
free night Queen b6 my late Grichuk
shakes his head or shut me in going down
in this one Wow Queen worried this is
just but if you're sure do you want to
play this out and go to overtime even
remember what the overtime procedure is
but
if the man chess made right on cue love
her the most if the mattress fight after
this last bowl game but I break a for
additional +1 book it was played in a
mini match if the match is still played
after the mini match tiebreaker a single
Armageddon game will be played 5 over
white 3 over black black at straws wow
just wow isn't white of a piece now I
mean like stop looking sort of I was
listening to you I stopped looking at
the board
oh we're probably assuming this ends in
the overtime that we're expecting we're
gonna have to let the players know this
because I doubt either of them knew the
rules that well yeah but I think they're
gonna have time for wow look at that
they've time for one more game one more
game
no overtime yet oh my we are officially
in overtime but the match is tied before
the format begins that means the winner
of this game unless this matches a draw
what was the 1970s it was not in
overtime did you see that I don't
understand I was like I blacked out
right they're looking for a staff member
to confirm for me the chess basic rules
were right even though I always believed
the chess play is right
what is this opening night least 7 to
cease increments is strange and it might
not be so terrible honestly but very
very bizarre and okay I think Sasha Inez
is gonna learn how to push palm on beef
three because that's really been his
downfall in these Sicilians is when he's
gon be three and allowed yeah but this
is this is potentially a really good one
for black cuz white wants a five in this
structure to keep it closed and he can't
you see Duda is so nervous right now
yeah this is phenomena so chess may as I
said if you didn't know that chess baby
was always right I've said it before and
I'll say it again she's always right she
was right so that is exactly what the
format will be we need to inform the
players you know Avon's Ivanka shook and
I am shook because I keep losing and
when I'm all the to ever two-game lead
it's one of those positions where you
don't want to take necessary take too
many risks and you say okay let me take
a breath remember what vidit told us
against the zabun when he went down to
zero
the postgame interview he said you know
I I just even this five-minute games I
just needed to spend some time so I
could breathe and get back in it so
maybe he's you know you shouldn't go in
and all cost by oh man well if it all
that we only get overtime if this is a
draw though and right now this this
doesn't both sides are a nervous flinch
away from blundering away the match and
Grichuk now with only 20 seconds on the
clock dude look at this we could do it
just playing super confidently laughs in
the face of danger on c4 Knight takes e5
okay Bishop e3 pawn seafloors it's a
complete queen a three Grichuk Wow g6 we
can use take it twice on g6 what isn't
queen III just winning no no this pawn
takes d4 now Queen e3 will be winning if
you let me do it takes f7 King f8 okay
commissioning a fait king a1 oh my god
it feels like brush 865 barely barely
goes move my bridge to g3 you have to
swing the rook to g3 only both so okay I
like this knowing so be d3 here do you
ever say it first
fine go d3 he's got it back though d3
where is he three where's the wind
he has d3 cos the pawn is pink we cease
recheck his clothing followed by takes
in c2 and it's over oh my gosh that that
is that no they they're playing again
playing again but the match is over the
match is over
oh wow and grishnak didn't know it Sasha
don't know he's heartbroken oh my gosh
oh my Wow
wow that's unbelievable unbelievable Wow
absolutely incredible
there is something you know do as this
put his like he's trying to hold back to
smile out of respect for Brooke I can
see it you know he's trying to rein in
but there's very little better to see
than seeing a young player like this
the smile just yeah Wow Wow the most
exciting finish we may have ever had
honestly with with like no exaggeration
down two games to go with five minutes
left
the on Christophe Duda wins the final
three games to take the match I think we
can hear you both now Alexander and
young Christoph are you there yeah well
thank you both for what is literally the
most exciting match we've ever had just
absolutely incredible
looks like young Christoph getting a hug
is that mom there yeah
well Sasha we know you're you're you're
devastated right now and I know it was
obviously a super tough finish but I
made amazing chess today Robert you have
a question in mind first cuz I'm kind of
speechless right now
I don't even know where to start I guess
firstly for young Christoph how did you
decide to switch between your openings
with the black pieces you you know had
the Sicilian then you went away to the
Petrov and then back to the Sicilian
what was going through your mind with
the opening changes well actually I
didn't prepare any special opening with
black I my only focus on what pieces
okay I thought Rob defense will be might
be sensible but okay I have retracted
with it so it was risky to played but
okay everything is risky luck did you
know young Christoph did you know after
you lost that game and you went down to
games 13 to 11 did you know that there
was only 5 minutes left
yeah I thought I was going to this match
at that moment because I was 2 points
behind and yeah ok I thought I would
have some good chances before he ball
right but I lost many positions which I
shoulda lost
and what yeah it was very very tough
moment for me two points behind okay my
mind okay in the beginning I was in
terrible shape I'm in a place back
beginner probably I spent too much time
today on computer and okay and then that
was happened but I played like we were
speculating about that you made some
huge blunders early on of this Queen a4
move obviously in the first Petroff and
and some people said that maybe you had
been studying chess all day and we were
like well maybe they're not maybe he has
been and and what did you be regretting
not not being a little more fresh at
that time and how did you wake yourself
up to kind of help turn things around
okay okay well penny for a maybe I wake
up at that moment because well the two
first games was where most frustrated
for me waiting because okay
in the first game I got okay much worse
position of cotton balls I think okay in
the second game I think it was better
with while but then completely miss play
it okay when they follow was the pinky a
shock but yeah maybe it was good I
branded it this way because yeah what a
blessing blunder in disguise well Sasha
it you know I know again I know this is
a heart a hard one right now and it
definitely felt like in many moments
this was your match for the taking you
jumped out to an early lead and then
things got away from you for a while but
you found it in the bullet and we're up
two games it was there in hindsight it
was there a regret at this point playing
playing very sharp openings once you
once you had that lead maybe a different
approach in the opening or do you have
any immediate thoughts on where you feel
like those last five minutes got away
from you no not at all just young played
better deserve the one congratulations
because I mean the most disappointing
thing for me was
the point when my chanted I had no idea
to whom I skip so there would be some
more games the biggest upset yeah well
it's a difficult difficult format we
know and previous to this the only
person who had ever beaten you in this
format was Magnus Carlsen and certainly
it seemed that you were on your way
there but obviously amazing chess today
by both of you guys and I don't know
that I have any chest specific questions
for you you guys played a lot of
Sicilians where were you surprised by a
young Christoph going into the openings
that he did as black or was this kind of
what you expected and your and your
thoughts or preparation you don't
expecting expected that she will be
something that there is no idea I mean I
had no idea which ones because he just
plays everything I mean I wasn't because
it was right well I don't know if I have
any more questions this is this has
really been speeches we have we've had
the highest viewers in this match
especially toward the end of any match
that we've had bands were glued to their
seats donating to the prize fund which
of course will that both you guys know
of the extra the extra funds coming your
way but this has been probably my
favorite match we've ever been a part of
it and thank you both for just fighting
chess all the way to the end and for
being gracious here in these interviews
Robert do you have any other questions
before we before we let them go and and
move on to the next round no honestly
still in disbelief both were deserve you
were deserving winners and really just
an epic battle definitely the best one
that we've had yet one of those matches
that if it kept going probably but it
kept going back and forth given how you
guys were but thank you again so much
Sasha and we know it's late there thank
you young Kristoff we also know it's
late there and we will hopefully see you
again next year
Sasha and young Kristoff I guess the
last question before we let you go as we
talk about the matchup that you will
face either video
rafi or Wesley so what are your thoughts
on either of those opponents and what
you would need to do to win and make it
to the finals
well actually I played many times
against both of them against did I
played on classical games I played with
black pieces but we play we played many
training games together and we know each
other quite well I think
okay against Wesley I had a bad scar but
like once I beat him in 1774 to black
because he at once dropped Queen and
what and once
and yeah probably I the shortest game
ever against as he saw but okay he is of
course very strong opponent and I'm -
scored against him but I've never played
the guys gaming online chess so that
helps okay well obviously we're all very
excited disappointed that not both of
you could go on at this point from from
the amazing chess we saw today again
Sascha agric thank you so much young
Christoph congratulations we will see
you in the next round and we're gonna
wish the best of you good luck and and
then say goodbye to fans giving you all
their things in the chat right now and
thank you both
you